timei I pre Lund whatever just before
Friday Monday Morning podcast what's
going
on how are
you sorry it was practicing my French
he's going again with the French here he
goes again what's he going to do first
learn French or actually quit cigars sh
say um all right before we get started
happy New Year and I got some
information for you my buddy my homie
the rosebowl tailgate Legend uh Joe
bartnik is going off on his first
headlining tour I'm so proud of the guy
Monday Morning podcast listeners you got
to go out and support this guy this guy
does the real deal as far as I'm
concerned when it comes to standup if
you live in
Ohio oh H IO Columbus Ohio hom you're
scarlet and gray Buckey Joe bartnik
January 11th we'll be headlining the
funny bone shout out to Dave
stro uh January 14th Joe bartnik is
bringing his new hour to the stress
Factory in New Jersey shout out to
Vinnie hey it fell off the truck brand
and then on January 25 25th January
25th
uh uh Philadelphia don't call it a
Philly cheese steak Philadelphia it's
just a [__] cheese steak uh he's at
The Parks Casino in Philadelphia January
25th
um you know go there and check them out
then one last thing I have to promote is
one of my own dates I'm going to be a
small part of the Bon
Scott tribute concert that Dean Del re
puts on and I got to tell you if you're
anywhere near La you got to come to the
show it's at the Avalon right across the
street from um Capital Records which is
a great Selfie by the way or if you go
with somebody else that's a great
picture legendary place um January 9th
this
Tuesday um we're going to be
uh we're going to be doing Dean's
putting on this it's basically it's a
standup show followed by a full-on
tribute concert to acdc's Bon Scott the
Bon Scott era Dean actually absolutely
killed it on Main vocals and he's going
to have all of these rock stars that are
his buddies from his time when he was
doing music are going to come down and
yours truly is going to jam on two ACDC
songs not easy songs I don't know why I
I picked them but uh I picked them CU I
love them but they are not easy songs to
play so it's been a nice challenge for
me uh that's going to be this Tuesday at
the Avalon there's still a few tickets
left I'm telling you I the last one we
did was was like literally the day
before the pandemic and I still get the
occasional tweet or Instagram message
from fans going like I just want to say
that was one of the coolest [__]
combination shows it's a killer standup
show followed by an absolutely
epic uh concert and uh it's all pro
musicians except for
me I'm the bathroom break guy and uh
it's just fantastic
so um with that here we are here we are
going into the first week I am uh three
days into
uh this [__] fast that I went on to
just sort of keep all of my demons at
bay uh it's obviously not to lose weight
cuz when you fast what happens they you
take your muscle muscle burns fat you
become actually a little more squishy
little more fleshy there but um I am not
uh I'll take the first day of it wasn't
bad it was just water with lemon and
some like electrolytes wasn't bad at
all
um I don't know it just wasn't bad but
like the last two days has been like
bone broth
GH and you know everybody buys the
chicken because it sort of just tastes
like the end of chicken noodle soup if
you heat it up but this [__] bone
broth oh my
God this it's it drinking bone broth
like room temperature bone broth like
beef
is like being in a relationship with
someone you never really loved in the
first place and it's just another
[__] day with them and you're like
what am I have to get out of
this now as I've stated for years I am
German Irish which means I can pretty
much block
out 98% of feelings if need be in order
to survive unless you get to death of a
friend a family member or literally
torture um anything else I'm just like
whatever I'll just [__] plow through
it it's it's the blessing and the curse
of having that blood flowing through my
veins and I will tell you this is the
only
thing uh I've always done well with like
dieting and I can just do it I just get
into the whole difficulty of it and I
sort of I don't know why I
just I actually enjoy it struggling in
the difficult parts of life I don't know
why and when good things are happening
I'm always looking for the other shoe to
drop in a way like you know oh dude the
crowd's great the crowd's great I'm
thinking like oh what if I bomb and then
everybody's like the crowd was great the
only person who bombed was Bill you know
or or and then I I felt way more
pressure when I was coming up if
somebody said oh dude the crowd's
[__] awful bunch of Meatheads and
[__] I actually would do way better
because there was no pressure I'm
supposed to do bad so then I would go up
there
relaxed and
um everything you do
relaxed is just better which I am
learning with drums I have this new way
of practicing taught to me by the great
Dave elich rather
than you know trying to make it happen
just relax and I I just rather than like
trying to play stuff up to Tempo my new
thing is how relaxed can I play this at
what tempo does it stop being relaxed
and [__] that back off drums are
supposed to be fun they're not supposed
to be stressful I remember a long time
ago I can't believe I have this story is
I did this benefit in Downtown LA and
one of the drummers playing on it is one
of my alltime favorites because I just
feel like he just has the most killer
feel and he's so creative and really
with just a four-piece kit did more with
that thing than a lot of the guys his
contemporaries were doing with like
double base kicks and three rack two
floor and all of these [__] symbols
he just got more goddamn music out the
great Steven
Adler and uh I went down there and he's
always just like to get the most
positive energy and he was saying and he
said what he he told me he goes make
sure you smile don't forget to smile and
relax and when you watch him play that's
how he plays and it just sounds so
[__] good and I didn't quite
understand
it cuz I was thinking relax it's like
I'm completely out of my element here I
need to be between my ears thinking what
I'm going to do and like it was just
some I I didn't I still sat down and
didn't quite do what he told me but then
I watched him
play and taking lessons with Dave was a
combination of both both of them so
thank you to both of them that I finally
got it it's like oh when you play
relaxed it sounds better it sounds more
powerful it has more flow to it or
whatever so it's something I've been
working on cuz uh you know I'm off the
road I'm not on the road right now and
if I have nothing to
do all of my [__] catches up with me
and I go into a depression so I need new
things cuz I've kind of put to bed
everything that happened to me up into
this point in my life but no matter how
much you put it to bed it still happened
and occasionally you're going to [__]
think about it or just revisit it or
whatever and then as I call it the fog
the smoke catches up with you so then
I'm like oh maybe I should start
learning some
French maybe I should take some drum
lessons hey there's a new place to get
coffee let me
[__] I'm just trying to keep me
mentally uh VFR right rather than
instrument rates yeah via IFR for you
Pilots out there so
anyway that is what I'm doing I am kind
of elated that I am at the end of
this this fast and the B big thing if
you ever do a fast is like by the end of
it like if you're out in the country and
you see a cow you start thinking of just
being doing what a bear would do which
is just tackle the thing and just start
biting meat out of its back like that's
what I feel
like with my [__] horse teeth here
this is what the I'm thinking of
doing um I was on Instagram and they had
the top 10 places to get a burger and I
was looking at that [__] yesterday
drinking this room temperature beef bone
broth and all I was thinking is like I'm
going to all [__] 10 of those places
and I am getting a burger maybe you know
10 in a row tomorrow and that's kind of
a really bad way to come out of a fast
so my buddy was saying you know maybe
get some avocados some
walnuts um cantaloupe just something
that's
easy um to kind of ease your way back in
because I had I went to a birthday party
last night and they had steak freets
they had this
pasta they had uh they had some chicken
and they had this giant birthday cake
and I just sitting there drinking ice
water with
lemon and uh you know everybody knew so
they were all [__] teasing
me and one of my buddies was going like
you can just sit here and do this it's
like dude I am about ready to [__]
just stick my face in any [__] plate
here
and I didn't and when I left it's just a
great party just a really good mix of
people when I left I got in my
truck and out loud to nobody as I made
this illegal
U-turn I just said I could eat 10 cheese
pizzas and just started laughing cuz I
said it so matter of factly and I knew I
wasn't lying obviously I couldn't eat 10
cheese pizzas but I would definitely be
up for
it um so anyway I'm going to uh I had a
really other than smoking a cigar every
[__] day from July until the end of
November which was really a massive
failure on my part maybe 15 or 20 days I
didn't
um I but I I lived a lot healthier last
year as far as not eating eating
desserts and [__] like that so then
something always has to go off the rails
so my new thing is I think if like once
a month I do this three-day fast because
somewhere through the second day it's
like your rational brain just takes over
and you start looking at you can just
look at food and other habits like
smoking and all of that objectively like
why would I do that where all of the
other times when you're sort of in the
throws of it salt sugar salt sugar smoke
smoke smoke caffeine
it's it's a different version of you
that is sort of like a hysterical woman
that needs to be slapped in an old
school
[Applause]
movie oh my God can you imagine if you
came up with a machine that shook your
shoulders and slapped you across the
face like one of those 1950s movies like
for Christ sake get a hoest no for
goodness sakes they didn't curse I love
if they wouldn't curse but you could hit
a woman um get a hold of yourself it was
always like one two right um which
airplane made fun of so hilariously uh
in their movie like 20 years after those
things um it'd be funny if you had like
you know like you know like those karate
people have like that that [__] white
dude it's that same white dude he and
what I love about him is he doesn't look
like somebody you could beat up he
definitely looks like he's a strong guy
but he's missing a whole body and he
can't move the one that you kick and
punch and all of that or that 49ers fan
punches in the face when he does when
he's talking about the game I've seen
those clips it's hilarious if you had
one of those but you added like hands
that could grab your shoulders like you
adjust it to how wide your shoulders are
and you know when you know that you're
going to eat something smoke something
do something you shouldn't [__] do it
just shakes you and goes for God's sakes
get a hold of yourself and it gives you
a forehand and a backand across the
face
um just just just a wake you up again I
don't know I don't know if any of this
makes sense I just like I need to
[__] I'm ready my fast ends at 9:00
tonight but I'm just going to go till
tomorrow morning because I don't want to
eat a bunch of [__] before I go to bed
so I'm going to start eating tomorrow
morning and during the fast like
everything I ordered had to do with food
like I'm obsessed with learning how to
make a a a ham and cheese uh jambon a
frage a fromage uh crepe and um I bought
the pan with the little [__] squeegee
that comes with it and I actually looked
I wrote In French how to make one cuz I
want somebody French to teach me how to
do it and what was funny was I've
watched enough food
um videos that I can kind of tell if
somebody knows what they're doing or if
they don't so the first one was a woman
and she had this shitty pot and a shitty
stove so right there I got to go okay
maybe she doesn't make a lot of money
but she's one of these people that you
go to her house and she just
makes regardless of her situation and
her equipment she just has the gift like
how uh Jack White can [__] take a
Sears store-bought guitar back in the
day and make it sound better than you
know some dad guitarist with the
[__] vintage Les Paul right so I'm
going all right let me watch this person
and where she lost me is when you go to
make the crepe you're doing like the
well method like Mario Batali uh rested
Soul uh mola Mario rested Soul um used
to do the well
method and I remember you put the three
eggs in there and then you gradually
Incorporated the flow and I was watching
all of these French uh people doing it
and I got to hers because the picture of
of of the Quant looked not the Quant The
Crepe looked really good she just she
made the well and she put the eggs in
there and I think she said in French but
you can do the well thing but it doesn't
really matter I just throw it so she
threw put all her milk in and all the
other [__] and stirred it up it still
looked all right but I really
believe slowly adding the liquids to the
to the powdered [__] right to the to the
solids whatever the [__] you call it so
I found this other guy and he had a
professional kitchen and he did the well
method and he slowly added the water so
um I don't even know what I'm talking
about or how long that [__] story
took but that's basically what I've been
doing as I am patiently
waiting for this Michigan Wolverine
Washington huskys game on
Monday uh which I think is going to be a
[__] classic because I kind of did a
little bit of research on the Washington
Huskies quarterback and he had he's had
to come back back from two ACL injuries
and he did that's the big thing people
will talk about oh he hurt his knees
twice yeah and you know what he did he
[__] came back both times dominated
and led his team to the championship
game so um I know the spread right now
is minus four but I think that's just
because a lot of people you know they
show up for the big game and they saw
Michigan beat Alabama and I don't think
that they realize that Alabama you know
like Nick Sabin did an incredible job
with that team this year because I I you
know they kind of started off Rocky they
they always have a loss in [__]
September but he writed the [__] but I I
I
just think they didn't have the
replacement players that they usually
have
um so I think it's a pick them and I'm
obviously rooting for Michigan but I
think it would be really cool to see the
huskys win a championship uh I wouldn't
be mad at that you know if it was
[__] USC or one of those [__]
teams that you just seen too many times
in the course of my lifetime I'd be like
[__] these guys right I I mean I am
rooting for Michigan but I I it it'll be
a lot easier to lose to the Huskies who
I didn't think had won a championship
since the 1950s and I just found out on
the anything better podcast that they
actually won one in
1991 with Mark Brunell the great
Jacksonville Jaguars
quarterback um so um
anyway I know I'm [__] yammering on
like I'm on coke I am allowed to have
coffee during this fast but I only do
one a day one a day plus iron like the
[__] gerol so I had one double
espresso before
this I'll tell you you know what's
[__] rough I'll tell you what's rough
I tell you a rough one is room
temperature beef bone broth followed by
a double espresso like I was all excited
like oh my God something with
flavor it it just all kind of tastes the
same at this point I mean that's I
almost have to apologize for you to even
have you guys to imagine chasing room
temperature beef bone broth with a
[__] Double
Espresso I mean I might as well just
drank it out of a [__]
ashtray
um oh my God what I could do with a
hamburger stand right now
I oh my God like I could [__] walk
that's why when you come out of a fast
you have to go I feel they say to go
easy it's it half of it is so you don't
shock your digestive system the other
half is so you don't
undo everything you just did cuz uh I am
a huge huge fan of the taco stands out
here taco trucks and the hamburger
stands like those those those little
ones they almost look like back in the
day remember when Kodak right outside
the KMOD used to have like their we
develop your films in [__] 24 hours
your your your
uh not your films your film from your
your camera or whatever they're like
that size I [__] love those places
and uh I don't think I've ever been to a
bad one the the worst they are is not as
good as a great one but I I
mean there's just something about it
you're
outside you know and I usually just go
with the burger I'm not into the fries
anymore I'm too [__] old to handle
that but just a [__] burger and a
root
beer you know I don't know there's
something about it sun's out out here
you feel like you're skipping school
like you should be doing something and
you're not
um oh my God I'm back into talking food
again this might be the most insane
I've been on any [__] podcast where I
keeps my the the the logical part of my
brain keeps going bill will you stop
talking about food and I can't help it
it's like I'm talking about this girl
that broke up with me and I never got
over it you know you ever have that
buddy you know I had a couple I had one
buddy like that and I always knew when
it was going to happen I could almost
time it by what he was drinking if it
was beers he'd have to be a little
deeper
in he'd have to be like like five in and
he would get that look on his face and I
I would be like all right number seven
he's going to come to me and it's going
to be it's going to be on and uh but if
he was drinking
Scotch it was
two two scotches in he'd start to get
Surly and then and then here we go it's
[Laughter]
again um
for
me it was never a
woman for me for the longest time it was
sporting
events it was game six of the 86 World
Series it was
uh there was never really any Patriots
thing we just always I was never
expecting us to win a Super Bowl out of
all the Championships we won that first
Super Bowl we won was more surprising to
me than the World
Series
um
yeah it was never the loss to the
Yankees like the Bucky Dent one I was
too young for it was the 86 one that was
my Bucky Dent game and then the Aaron
Boon one it happened but before it took
root we won the next year so it
never you know quite took
hold
um basketball it was
87 that first time we lost to the Lakers
and they won the championship in the
Boston Garden I always remember Kareem
hit another Skyhook that like it was
already iced and then it was definitely
iced and he ran up the court and he
[__] Bol his fists was like yeah and
then they they celebrated in the Boston
Garden and historically back then the
Lakers always lost to the Celtics they
had never beaten Us in the final NBA
final that's the plural one Stanley Cup
finals Stanley Cup finals
um and they they celebrated in the
Boston Garden and drank champagne there
and I bet all the Championships that
they won I bet if you asked magika
Kareem there was no sweeter champagne
than the one the the champagne they
drank in the visitor's locker room H I
still remember where I watched that game
and I remember walking
out
of my buddy's house into the
street and
uh we I was it was it was like yeah it
was awful and that was like less than a
year after
[__] the Red Sox but the Red Sox she
expected it the Celtics was just
like they just win they they [__] win
and it was also Len Bias died 86 was
[__] brutal Len Bas
died we [__] blew
it and uh the Celtics won it all and
then it was just Len Bas died Bill
Buckner the Patriots getting absolutely
[__]
smoked against the the 85 bear oh that
was 85 so the beginning of the year was
that yeah the Celtics winning the
championship was the 86 oh tell you that
was a rough one okay um there's a good
question if you come from a city with uh
three to four major sports teams or
maybe even just two like
Buffalo um what
uh the worst Sports
year versus the
best um I'd say the best for us was 2004
beating the Yankees finally winning a
World Series and then also winning a
Super Bowl our third one that year I
think and then the worst year in sports
I would say was
86 with uh The Buckner loss and Len Bas
dying um was just [__] brutal that
was so bad I mean and also like can you
imagine okay the
Lakers you know what they would have to
do to deal with the fact that we had the
Celtics finally had a Showtime
Laker level
player um
who used to go blow for blow in games
against Michael Jordan in
college
um not saying we definitely would have
want it but just
watching that whole franchise have to
deal with that um would have caused if
you can believe this magic and Kareem
and worthy to have to elevate their game
from where it was I mean you know even
if we lost even if we still [__] lost
just like
what you missed out on a fan forget
about seeing a kid in the prime of his
life about to make the full dream come
true pass away like that's [__]
brutal which is sad why would I bring
that up it's the be it's the new year
right everybody we're doing stuff this
year we're not going to let 24-hour
networks divide us anymore we're going
to come
together we're going to have more
empathy right
liberals
conservatives
centrists
uh faith in humanity
something um anyway uh I don't know what
the [__] else to talk about I will not
talk about food oh is there anything
better than a [__]
Reuben
H two eggs over easy hash browns bacon a
cup of [__] coffee in today's
newspaper in a
diner like if there was a genie right
now and he granted me three wishes you'd
think you'd go with World Peace the
first [__] time the first wish would
be
that and then World Peace
um anyway uh yeah so please guys go see
uh Joe bartnik I can't I can't think of
anybody else that deserves who's been
working as long as he has he's so
excited to do these dates and I he was
at the Rose Bowl and uh he was telling
me how excited he was about his new
material and uh I could just feel his
energy that he's going to do some
[__] damage and those you will not
regret the money you spend seeing him
nor if you live in the LA area if you
want to come down see me and Dean do
some
standup and then all these amazing
musicians uh tip their cap to the great
Bon Scott and one of the greatest fans
of all time ACDC
that that shows on
Tuesday and
um I don't know uh J say I don't know
what else I have for you I think that's
it all right um happy New Year once
again to everybody uh I'm going to do a
bunch of
spots around town here in LA and I am
going to
uh polish off this new 15 that I have
and uh I'm going to tape a special this
year that's the plan anyway and um
I have all my dates on my website and I
have a few surprise ones that are in the
works that I am very very
excited about and uh you know I want to
be at the top of my [__] game
mentally and physically you know go out
there and give you guys your money's
worth because as I've said a bunch of
times I can't tell you guys how much I
appreciate the fact that you listen to
this podcast and you give a [__] enough
to go to my shows and you watched old
dads and you watch Leo
so um I have no plans on phoning
anything in never did never will so
thank you in advance if you come out to
any of my shows and if you don't I
understand you're [__] busy whatever
just have a good year this year all
right and uh I don't know I'm hoping
regular people can [__] come together
and stop listening to these [__]
sociopaths that are trying to divide us
all right I'm off my I'm off my
uh I usually say tree stump but now I
say Butcher Block because that's all I
can [__] think of right now is
ordering [__] some food from them all
right that's it uh enjoy the music
picked out by the amazing Andrew Themis
and then we have a bonus episode of the
Thursday afternoon just before uh Friday
Monday Morning podcast that's it you
guys have a great weekend you [__] and
I will check I will not check in on you
I will talk to you on
Monday hey what's going on it's Bill
Burr and it's time for the Monday
Morning podcast for Monday January 4th
2016 a brand new year brand new year
brand new you are you going to make the
changes that you've always wanted to
make what are you going to stop telling
yourself you're going to change and
actually go out there and
change I always love to
pressure the beginning of the new year
to be like all right you know there's
that one great thing right like what you
you like all right shaking off the last
year you know like I don't know who the
[__] that guy was right like lying to
yourself like you're not the same person
[__] one minute later when it becomes
a new year or you do the real childish
thing is you blame everybody else for
your own [__] problems you know can't
wait for this year to be over man just
been so much [__] [__] this year
it's been like the worst [__] year I
can't wait for the next [__] year
it's like dude well are you going to
change anything you going to break up
with the person are you going to stop
getting drunk and being a dick and
picking fights in the bar right huh all
of that [__] or you just going to think
that magically because there's a six
there now instead of a five that all of
a sudden the world's going to change you
don't have to adjust oh am I
reprimanding somebody right now I think
I am I don't know why I have no idea why
I'm recording this uh at about 8:30 in
the morning lost hung's time my wife's
still sleeping downstairs so I I got to
I got to try to stay at medium
energy medium energy here um for the
rest of this [__] podcast
um but whatever I'm kind of I got to be
honest with you I went to bed last night
and I was sad I love the holidays and
I'm sad that they're [__] over I had
another great you know holiday break and
to think that it's all going to [__]
start over again you know here we
go another [__] year at doing the
road
writing [__] and doing all this stuff
here we [__] go again and the whole
thing just got o just totally
overwhelming with me and I was just
[__] laying in bed you know you know
when you you [__] look too far ahead
into your [__]
life
um you know it just gets too [__]
overwhelming and then maybe you start
hearing the same you know what song I
always hear in my head I always hear
that that song Make the World Go
Away something something and get it off
my
shoulders um that's what I feel like the
most pathetic emotion you could have
make the world go away and you're just
going to go in there and just pout you
know I got to ask a question about
depression is it actually a chemical
thing or is that just an adult world
word for like somebody who's just kind
sort of pouting you know I think a lot
of times when people go on depressed
it's just you're just kind of feeling
sorry for yourself and you know the ones
that say it's like a chemical imbalance
you just like you just shift your head
really quickly the chemicals go back the
other way and you'll cheer up you know
don't believe the mainstream
media you know and all the
pharmaceutical companies with their
drugs
[Music]
man is there anything funnier than when
somebody who's not a [__]
doctor you know just starts going on and
on about let me tell you something man
I'm telling you all you got to do is
just go up walk up to an oak tree can't
be a birch can't be a maple go up to an
oak tree and just bite on the little
sapling you just no it right you got a
little piece of bark and you stick it
between you just like chew you just
stick it between your gum and all of
that and your depression will go
away yeah it is true it is true the
Native Americans used to do it and they
were never depressed
that's what they used to do until the
white man came and took their bark away
now look at them all grumpy just like
the white man cuz they cuz they couldn't
get any more saplings with the tree bark
there um anyways uh fzy and his wife
left yesterday so the house is empty
again it just stinks man I was having a
great [__] time enjoying it now it's
going all it all [__] starts over
again um I'm already starting the year
off my office is a [__]
mess you know I'm the worst I can't find
the sticker to put on my [__] license
plate I know I got it I don't know where
the [__] it is it just it all starts
over just fun time's over fun time is
over you know what we still got the
Christmas tree up because Nia liked it
extra a lot this year so I still have to
I still have to go through that sad
[__]
operation of bringing that goddamn thing
outside and I told you I dispose that
thing like a a [__] mob hit you're
never going to find the body my [__]
neighbor already threw his right out on
the street just tosses it out there
right some dead hooker you know what I
mean cut the [__] thing up and you
put it in the barrel that's what you
do I get mine my the green Barrel right
we got the green barrels out here and
that's just like grass clippings and all
that [__] I have a whole [__]
Christmas tree in there and the lid
closes completely you'd have no [__]
idea I mean come on people how difficult
is it you cut all the branch off then
you just left with the trunk and then
you just section it up that's it drop
the thing right the [__] in there it's
not a
problem you wait your safety goggles you
know so nobody can see you crying as
you're doing it I don't understand what
the [__] problem is now God damn it
get out there and dispose of the [__]
tree
correctly um environmentally wouldn't it
be more correct if you just sort of
spread it across your lawn the tree is
just going to end up in a landfill or
even worse out in the ocean they don't
BL of the
ocean um I can't wait to get to this
[__] thing later on in this podcast
where this guy is's trying to claim that
the uh the Earth can sustain 100 billion
people I really cannot I cannot wait to
I just glanced at it and looked at it
and it's just I I
just how the [__] you arrived at that
number and I actually tried to find [__]
I started looking up how many [__]
people the Earth can
sustain and uh what I immediately found
was that nobody could say for certain
but the numberers estimated we're
nowhere near 100 million [__] people
100 billion sorry so I cannot wait to
read this guy somehow claiming that
there's enough
Farmland to feed a 100
[__] billion people I don't okay do
we stack each other on top of one
another and even then do elephants get
to roam free
anymore where are all the [__]
animals um if there was 100 billion
people on the planet I would think that
cannibalism would slowly start to become
legal they would have uh they'd have
Farm people or stock people that's what
they call them and they would be simply
be
um used for
food you know we just you know and of
course it would be uh you know the evil
white man would decide who it is that
gets eaten first you know maybe they'd
start with like the pygmies or something
like that because it' be like all right
well you know they're uh they are of a
particular race but they're not as tall
as most people in that race so you know
they're sort of bite-sized they're like
sliders right sliders they're like human
sliders you know get a little honey bun
you know stick a [__] ankle between
the two right why would you eat an ankle
ankle
meat
um so anyways I I still feel [__] up
from the road Rose Bowl man I still you
know I barely got any sleep with Paul
being out here and then we also
performed New Year's Eve uh down the
Orum and I bought this suit to wear New
Year's Eve I found it like over the
summertime it was this all white
suit jacket and pants but you know from
from a distance it reads all white but
when you come up to it it had these tiny
black poka dots you know what I mean
just tiny and uh I walked into the store
and it was on like the [__] 70% off
rack because it's really one of those
things like where the [__] are you ever
going to wear that and I saw I was like
that's a perfect suit for [__] New
Year you put the black [__] solid
black shirt underneath it with a little
black pocket square right and you walk
out there like John
Travolta well you can't tell by the way
I tell my jokes I'm a [__]
hack no time for
originality I'm sorry
[__] [__] jokes [__] jokes I don't
like to use
Concepts anyways so that was once again
me standing to the side of the stage
going like uh I am either going people
either going to like this suit or I'm
going to get heckled the entire time I'm
out here but either way either way it's
going to add to the [__] show but
uh as I predicted it was New Year's I
addressed the suit I said this is the
only night I could wear it and people
left and it was a uh it was a great
[__] time great old theater and uh I
had a bunch of people come
out
um bunch of friends you know people I
had seen in a couple years people that
you know kind of in my life it was
awesome man I love doing New Years out
here in La cuz
uh I don't have to travel or anything
like that and I get to do the job I love
to do however I think that's the last
New Year's Eve I'll do I think I'll do
like the 30th next time because I got to
tell you the second show ends right by
the way I had had to do the countdown
like like two jokes before my closing
joke I was like halfway through this one
bit that I've been trying to work on I
kept [__] up the ending and I was
going to try a new ending to it cuz the
ending was too sad for every [__]
City in this nation other than Dallas
Texas Dallas Texas [__] enjoyed the
[__] out of the original ending
um and I'm right in the middle of that
bit and I see that it's 1159 so then I
had to get out of the bit take a pause
and then do the countdown and then the
streamers came out right lovely Nia came
out on stage gave me a kiss all the guys
came you know we [__] waved and
everything and then everybody gets off
the stage and then I had to go back into
my ACT which was
uh uh I don't know it just ended up
being funny because it was really weird
so anyways um we end up doing the
show and then as we
leave um we're stuck in this brutal
traffic I'm like what the [__] there
must have been something going on cuz we
were down downtown LA there must have
been something going on um down at like
LA Live or some [__] down there that's
right near the Staple Center and then I
[__] realized the next day it was
Motley crew's final show
ever at the Staple Center and
um so I was like ah [__] that's the
traffic we got stuck in and there's
actually a clip Up on YouTube of you
know Tommy Lee the drummer does has a
whole [__] roller coaster attached to
his drum kit where it turns upside down
and it goes out over the crowd and then
comes back and all that [__] I mean
right there
alone you know if you're the other
members in the band you got to be like
dude this better be [__] worth it
because the amount of money that's
coming out of our checks to [__]
carry that rig out on the [__] road
you know what I mean that's one of those
overhead cost so I don't know if you
guys have seen the video it's their last
[__] show ever and the thing gets
stuck it gets stuck and Tommy is upside
down on this thing and this Ro
scampering up the side of it like the
[__] apes and Planet of the Apes when
they were on the Golden Gate Bridge
right they're scampering up the side of
this thing and Tommy's just upside down
like what the [__]
man the [__] thing's
busted he's like hey La he's like what
you look you look interesting when I'm
hanging upside down in Los Angeles and
he's just hanging upside
down it's the most excruciatingly
uncomfortable thing I've seen a
performer have to go through in a long
time he did what the [__] he could
do I mean once you just go well [__] the
roller coaster man and you're still
hanging upside down I mean what do you
do it's just [__]
brutal and the fact that it happened on
the very last show you know I don't want
to start any
infighting I know the band doesn't exist
anymore but I think Vince Neil did it I
think the lead singer probably all these
years you know he's used to being out
front all the chicks digging him you
know walking around with his Barbie hair
and all that and then all the drummer
goes all the way out over the crowd and
everybody's looking at him and maybe he
got sick of it after all these years the
amount of money that was coming out of
his paycheck to bring that [__]
loop-de-loop roller coaster with the
[__] drum kit in it and he probably
went he probably said hey everybody look
at that over there and then he just
pulled the
fuse uh that doesn't make any sense bill
then he's sabotaging his own show well
you
know I can have a [__] Theory
somebody can just email me with no
[__] links or anything whatsoever and
just tell me that the Earth can sustain
100 billion
people
anyways so we uh we're stuck in that
traffic I didn't get home until like uh
1:30 1:45
fell asleep around 2: and then I had to
be up at 10: 10 after 5: to then be
outside for the next 13 hours at the uh
at the Rose Bowl this year we brought
eight people and
um one of my buddies who went there he
just called it the Goon parade and I got
to be honest with you uh that's kind of
what we
were um I don't remember so much of it I
remember the whole game cuz I just
stopped drinking cuz I had to drive so I
just remember walking to the stadium and
after that I remember the entire [__]
game um so I'll take you through what I
remember so we [__] get there right
first time ever we get there so [__]
early that they haven't even open the
gates yet so when we finally get in
we're parked just outside the VIP
parking I mean we had like a 5 minute
walk to the stadium was [__]
tremendous and uh I remember bartnik
giving me a Miller High Life the big
grin on his face cuz we always have the
Miller High Life to start the day
lawhead got his [__] why had made it
by the way he made it you know I'll
Never Smile Again um he made it and uh
he got all three of his fires going and
getting ready for the breakfast
sandwiches and I want to say that I
waited till after I had laads
unbelievable breakfast sandwich it's the
best breakfast sandwich I have every
[__] year is that one and it was
absolutely delicious and my favorite
thing was looking over at verie after he
was two bites in and I was like hey Paul
I go how's that breakfast sandwich and
he just [__] shot me it looked like
are you [__] kidding me so I was
already psyched and I knew he was going
to have a great time and um after that I
was like hey I'm like who wants a heater
and everybody's like yeah all right so
he poured like [__] eight of them and
I had these these those big Square ice
cubes I had made those and brought them
over and a Ziploc bag like a [__] you
know kilo of coke so I drop them into
everybody's plastic cup and they're so
big they don't make it all the way down
to the bottom of the glass so the booze
is actually below the ice level and
everybody's laughing I'm like well you
just got to
[__] you got to pour more booze in
there and then you put your hand over
the Ice Cube and it'll melt down and
that became the technique and then after
that it just became like a slides shell
just the stuff I
remember I remember uh bartnik does this
thing every year he gets off the you
know gets out of the truck and he just
screams at the top of his lungs ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the Grand Daddy
of them all and everybody's always
terrified sort of laughing whatever so
these Iowa fans somebody just said H we
do not need that voice here and
immediately we're not liking us and
uh I don't know I think that for
whatever reason they were really they
were
like I want to say older than me but I'm
pretty [__] old at this point I'm 47
I think they were in their 50s and for
whatever
reason they were playing Drake all right
and it was like [__] 7 in the morning
and their [__] music was louder than
our music so we're sitting there the sun
hasn't even come up yet and we listening
to you used to call me on your cell
phone you used to you used to
and it's just was [__] like oh God
are they going to be playing that
[__] song like that song is like
that's like there's a few songs that get
played so much that you never need to
hear them again I think the the original
song was in the
mood but I think Benny Goodman or was it
Glenn
Miller I never need to hear that song
ever again right I'd say book ending
from way back in the day to [__]
right now it goes in the mood Glenn
Miller and then uh cell
phone by
Drake
[Music]
I only mean one thing oh he's such a
[__] in that [__] song it's
basically hey I used to just [__] you I
used to I use you and then he she moves
away and then he's upset that the woman
got on with the
life you know
what a [__] is he one of those
possessive guys who once he [__]
something he feels like he owns it for
the rest of his life let it go
dude all you were doing was [__] her
and now what now you want her because
she's not there
anymore to come over and lick your balls
and shape up your beard afterwards I
mean [__] move on with your life
Drake yo yo yo yo y so that's [__]
going on and all I know and they were
annoyed with how loud bartnik yelled so
I don't know what happened somewhere
between the beer the shot and the
breakfast sandwich I glance over and the
older guy is chirping in [__] bartnik
ear and bartnik is just staring Straight
Ahead 600 yard stare just standing there
and I see the guy talking talking
talking and then I just see Joe just
shrug his shoulders and be like well you
know I don't like your
music
and I gotta be honest with you [__] I
don't know what else he said but 10
minutes later those people were just
gone and we never saw them again I don't
know if they had like some VIP [__]
you know Iowa Hawkeye
[__] barbecue thing the tent that
they were going to I have no idea but we
were D and laughing they had one
conversation with Joe like the hey do
you mind keeping it down a little bit
and Joe just gave him the death [__]
you know the 600 yard
stair and uh that was it they just
[__] left so that problem was solved
and we were throwing the football
around I remembered everything but
forgot the bacon and uh what's his face
lawhead was able to call in Audible and
he had some bison meat or something like
that and bacon grease figure that one
out I I don't know how the [__] he did
it but
um yeah and everything was going great I
was throwing the football around and
then at some point I was just so [__]
hammered that I I fell
down and I was one of those drunk falls
where it took me like 17 I started
falling and it took like 17 seconds for
me to fall and the entire time I was
saying I'm sorry um it's now known yeah
it's now known as the I'm sorry fall and
it took me so long to fall that just
about everybody at the tailgate saw it
and and uh I think if what I happened
was I was
standing liad had this tent you know one
of those four posted 10 Things I was
standing underneath it and unbeknownst
to me was right behind me was my cooler
and all the other coolers and all the
bags of groceries sort of sprinkled out
right and I was talking and I did an
about face to start walking and
immediately tripped over the first
cooler all right and as I was trying to
get my leg to an open area without
stepping on hamburger buns I just you
know there wasn't any space to put my
feet down and I was doing like it was
almost like a wide receiver after they
catch a football and they try to stay in
bounds and dance down the sidelines I
was doing that but in between condiments
and food and [__] like that and I just I
never regained my balance but I didn't
go down for I swear to God it it was
probably real time was probably like a
4C fall but that's a long time you know
if you just fall bam you're on the
ground you know in under a second right
I would think depending unless you're
really short and you get there a little
quicker so I just kept going sorry sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry and right is like my
buddy Nate came over to try and stop me
from falling I just I [__] landed on
my back and I twisted my left
knee and I hear the whole place laughing
and I was laughing evidently my last
step I stepped in some avocado and
slipped on that and I just [__] went
down like just thud right on my back I
landed like a wrestler so it didn't even
hurt where it was just my entire
backside hit the ground at the same time
and um I remember talking about it later
and I was like yeah but I didn't spill
my drink I didn't spill my drink and
everybody's like yeah you did you did
you spilled it all with the front of
your
jacket so
um then I remembered getting the the
apple pies out I remember the brisket
getting the ribs being done and those
were delicious L had killing it as
always and then
um I think I smoked a cigar
next yeah I smoked a
cigar and then we had the apple pies and
everybody freaked out and they loved
them and then I was yeah then I smoked a
cigar and I was like all right I got to
[__] sober up here because uh in 6
hours the game will be over and we'll be
done and then I got to drive
so um a [__] hang on a second hang on
all right I'm back sorry about that had
to blow my [__] nose so anyway so
then we get into the uh we get into the
game and I still don't know his [__]
name because I was hammered um the
running back for Stanford just was right
as we got in the stadium he already ran
for a touchdown and then it was just
like it was like a [__] Hollywood
movie they couldn't stop this kid the
kid even had another one he ran like 70
yards for a touchdown they had to bring
it back they just couldn't couldn't
[__] get the kid
down
um and before you knew it it was like 28
to nothing 28 to nothing then it was 35
to nothing and we we still had like half
half of the second quarter the [__]
game was just over it's it was the worst
Rose Bowl game as far as being
competitive that I've been to slash the
greatest individual performance I've
ever seen we got to see that kid he set
the record for the most allpurpose yards
ever in a Rose
Bowl um and this is the granddaddy of
amals the original Rose uh original uh I
guess bowl
game um even though the Yale bowl is the
original Bowl Stadium figure that one up
anyways um so we got to see that and
fortunately during halftime I didn't
have to watch the Stanford
band
um which by the way is just I mean could
you could they be more of a bunch of
hipsters the the whole thing it's like
they're mocking the halftime show yet
not showing how you can improve it so
there's like no risk you're just sort of
mocking the whole [__] thing like
which is to me classic hipster
Behavior Uh to me that's the difference
between nerds and hipsters you know what
I mean it's like all right so you think
what the the the standard way that a
halftime show is done is too rigid so
you guys are going I just hate how the
whole thing's done oh these guys are
crazy oh look at the guy with the
[__] rainbow wig playing the drum oh
what's he going to do that whole thing
is [__] dumb and then I just thought
it was a bad they made California look
bad when they made fun of the Iowa
people with the whole uh you know
Farmers Only and once again I don't know
I don't know anybody in the Stanford
band but it just seems like that classic
I live near an ocean therefore I'm
smarter than you there's something about
people live on the coast with their
whole attitude towards the middle of the
country It's the funniest [__] thing
ever to me like fly over State and blah
blah blah blah blah and all that it's
like those [__] people that you're
sitting there making fun of you know
like Farmers Only He why don't you go
out there and go [__] your sister it's
like you mean the people who who grow
the food supply for this country you
[__] dope what are you doing huh with
your flute oh oh look at the cool kid
with the clarinet I don't know I thought
it was a hacky joke and
um I don't know you know what I mean
look if you guys were you know just
decided to trash one another then it
would be funny but it just kind of comes
off like uh it's like when Ricky jves
does that [__] at the Golden Globes you
know what I mean he hires a staff of
writers to write roast jokes aimed at
people who showed up with acceptance
speeches and it's just oh G did you win
that one what are you going to do next
slap an ice cream out of a 5-year-old
hand I just I don't know it's the same
thing with that I thought it was douchy
Behavior but fortunately I missed all of
it you know and you we come out with the
paper M Shake cow it'll be
epic H kill yourselves it'd be one thing
if Stanford ever actually put on a good
halftime show like wow this band is next
level I get why they're trying to break
the whole [__] format of it but if
you actually watch uh the competitions
of the best [__] College bands out
there their [__] drum lines
alone would destroy anyone in that band
so uh you know I don't know every once
in a while I'm a [__] conservative
and I'm a conservative on that one I
just yeah you kind of [__] made an
ass of yourself but anyways I just hate
the deliberately bad dancing that they
do I think if you're going to mock
dancing you should be able to dance well
you know to just suck at it and then be
like making fun of it then you just
[__] like all
right yeah yeah just like we thought
yeah you don't have any
Talent [__] the Stanford band I love
them football program though anyways uh
so while all of that was going on all
that that [__] nauseating hipster
Behavior H the looks on their faces like
everyone in the crowd is like their mind
is blown like oh my God what's going on
it's the [__] H you're in the
band you're playing the [__] triangle
out there you're not a rebel you're not
freaking anybody out
um so anyways uh we actually went out to
the concession
stand and um you know just standing the
whole [__] halftime was standing this
in this in this line and we actually
missed the first three minutes of the uh
the third quarter and I'm standing in
this line with comedian Sean Quinn from
Philly he's [__] hilarious right so
we get all the way up there and uh I
ordered a pretzel and a water and he
ordered a pretzel and something else
else and uh I'm [__] coming around
he's still drinking you know he doesn't
have to drive so he's still [__]
drinking during the game and they hand
him the pretzel and he proceeds after we
waited a half an hour for our food she
hands him the pretzel and he [__]
just fumbled it it was like a bad
exchange between the quarterback and the
running back you know they like bump
into each other or the dude never quite
has the ball he never quite had the
pretzel and it just goes end overend and
like slow motion and Falls salts side
down onto the concrete where everybody's
standing he immediately bends down and
picks it up and I'm looking at him and
he just goes he's like yeah it's all
right it's all right I'm like dude you
got to give that thing back and he's
like no it's all right it's all right
right he doesn't give a [__] so I'm
dying laughing like this guy's a
maniac it's like people walking in and
out of restrooms and then coming over
here standing in this food line he out
of your [__] mind but I'm still kind
of drunk so then I go over we we're
putting mustard on the pretzel
and then out of nowhere [__] laad
shows up and he asked he asked Sean for
the piece of his pretzel and he gave it
to him I almost [__] fainted I was
laughing so hard [__] thing was on
the
ground I was
like was like watching him poison him
but I couldn't say anything I was
laughing so [__] hard so uh then we
get we finally get back into the uh
finally get back into the um the stadium
and then just the whole game just
stopped I mean there was barely any
scoring Iowa came back and scored a
couple um I was psych for verie cuz he
uh he won two bets he he bet Stanford
and then in the next half he bet the
over he won both of them so he picked up
a buck 50 or something like that and
um I don't know then we just ended up
going back the game was
over and then we went back to uh the
truck we were hanging out we got the
bonfire going the sun was
down and in the middle of having the
bonfire all of a sudden this kid comes
walking by with another friend this Iowa
kid and he just
goes he just goes hey he goes hey that
bonfire is illegal you can't have it
it's illegal and right as he was by be
like go like ha haa I'm just [__]
around the Philly guy
he goes oh shut the [__] up you [__]
blah blah blah right and then the
kid [__] puffs up his chest there's
like 10 of us sitting here this kid was
like uh he was like 56
5'7 he comes running up you know talking
all this [__] and I'm just sitting there
looking at him like there's [__] 10
of us here you know do you have an Uzi
like what are you doing right so he gets
into it it's back and forth the next
thing you know ver is over there and it
looks like ver is about ready to square
off with the guy cuz the guy kept
walking away like all right all right
whatever whatever and he'd be like all
right fine fine fine but [__] you cuz
we'd always had the last thing and then
we'd be like [__] you and it just kept
going back and forth and back and forth
then finally the guy's like 30 yards
away V's talking to him and I thought
like oh this kid's going to sucker him
so I got up over there I'm going relax
relax relax and then all of a sudden I
hear a bottle
break
and this [__] Maniac Philly guy right
[__] breaks the bottle that's the
funniest thing ever he breaks the bottle
on the pavement and he [__] he did it
way too hard when he brought his hand up
there was no bottle left he just
shattered the [__] thing but then he
like mimed like he still had the bottle
in his hand and this is the best part
the Iowa kid talking [__] never
flinched so now he's pretending he had a
bottle in his hand I didn't even know
what he was going to do it was like a
[__] movie just like what the [__]
right so the dude finally goes away has
to yell a few more [__] things and
um it was so ridiculous then we went
back and we we were sitting around and
all we did for the rest of the time
there was make fun of Sean and how there
was no bottle left and he actually cut
his hand and we were all just sitting
there going like dude what were you
gonna do and he's like I don't know I
don't know what I always wanted to do
that it was just
it's [__] ridiculous so
um and by then you know actually as I
was coming out of the game I I was I was
so sober I had already got gotten into
the [__] hangover so I just started
drinking Waters and
um then had another two hot dogs and a
hamburger and I got to tell you dude my
body was like what the
[__] and I just drove
home like with a splitting [__]
headache Stone sober splitting [__]
headache and um and then by then my knee
was killing me and I was walking like I
had just ridden a horse from here to
[__]
Massachusetts and I was I was
shot I came home and I just [__] just
pounded like three
Waters and that was it was during that
time where I was just thinking to myself
like I'm never going to that game again
I I I [__] you know when you're out 3 to
6 weeks with a [__] knee strain cuz
you went to a tailgate you really got to
start like looking back going like what
the [__] but it happened to me again
this year you know every year I'm going
you know I'm going to go a little
easy going to go easy I want to remember
as much of this tailgate as I can like I
passed out for like an hour of it and
part of it was the alcohol but the other
part was just like I'd only gotten 3
hours sleep you know there's only so far
you can go when you start the day off
with a mil
all right let me
um but it was one of the one of the best
uh one of the best [__] tailgates and
I loved hanging with [__] uh all the
new people that came along and I'm now
of course obsessed with the Philly
accent It's the funniest [__]
accent you got a bed b
[__] everything's a John um all right
hang on a second all
right let me type in my password so I
can do a couple of reads come
on I love how they make you pick such a
[__] difficult one that you know it
takes me like three times to type mying
because there's some capitals and then
there's some not capitals like if
someone broke it in my computer I don't
understand what they would be
getting um all right okay oh Jesus I
don't even know if I have the [__]
energy it usually takes it takes me
three days to get over the [__] Rose
bow this is the third day all right uh
oh oh look we start
up all right and that's it mercifully
that's the last bit of reading I have to
do here for the [__] week um all
right and with that let's get to
uh oh can we talk a little NFL football
first
what I would say the Patriots in Seattle
entered the playoffs the exact opposite
way I'm going to go out on a limb uh the
Patriots just could not get anything
going
offensively um our offensive line is
just uh it's it's it's [__] shed dude
we got nobody left every time Brady went
to pass there was someone in the back
field um our defense did great though I
mean was holding them to like 10 points
for most of the [__] game but um
hopefully we can get healthy or I don't
I don't see us going too deep into the
playoffs this year Seattle on the other
T I'll tell you right now this is the
wild card team nobody wants to play but
you got to ask yourself are they peing
too early Seattle
look like World beaters and the way that
they handled the [__] Cardinals
yesterday they made them I mean I don't
know if the Cardinals started to come
back or not I mean I watched the first
[__] half and it looked like an NFL
team playing a CFL team let me check out
the final score here
um I mean I think it's just
another phenomenal coaching job by Pete
Caroll
um and he's got like he's got him right
oh 36 to6 yeah they just destroyed him
scoring at will doing whatever the
whatever the [__] they wanted you know
Arizona special teams was looking like
[__] their field goal kicker mied a
couple extra points I don't know what
the [__] was going on with them and they
couldn't tackle anybody on punts or
kickoffs the only um question mark I saw
was
Seattle was their kicker missed another
one and Richard Sherman's hair that's
the only thing I found that's the second
time this year Sherman has been brought
down by by his hair um to the point they
actually thought it was a face mask he
went down so [__] his head went down
uh but other than that
uh I was I was the guy you know a couple
weeks ago thinking like you know
Arizona and uh Carolina now I think it's
uh uh Carolina is would play Seattle at
home but I got to tell
you Seattle doesn't give a [__] they've
been there the last two years in a row
um if they win it again this year A lot
of people are going to be like oh they
they were one play away for winning it
three times in a row that's absolute
[__] that's absolute [__] um you
win two in a row if you win the [__]
thing it changes it changes your Vibe
you know defending versus bad taste in
your mouth you know what I
mean how long do you think Pete carols
was able to actually get eight hours
sleep after that Super Bowl like the
drive that he's had to get back because
that they [__] that thing up slash
Malcolm Butler made one of the greatest
defensive plays of all time like that'll
you know there's a reason why nobody's
ever won three in a row it's you
know it's hard to stay that [__]
motivated I think anyways um and I know
watching the Patriots when they
defending Super Bowl champions versus
just being the Patriots which is bad
enough people want to beat you bad
enough but when you're the defending
Super Bowl champion even the [__] teams
try hard against you um but anyways
having said all that
um you know the way Seattle's played
over the last month in that last game
like they look like [__] world
beaters
um so and us I don't know if we could
beat the Broncos at this point with how
[__] injured we are even with their
uh their new quarterback I that was hard
to see pton Manning be a backup man but
he took it like a gentleman uh um I
wonder if that was his last
game I wonder I wonder I wonder all
right let's get to uh let's get to the
[__] questions here for this week
right and by the way um for all the
Canadian fans I'm not ducking the fact
that you guys destroyed us in that game
I just haven't seen it yet I started to
watch it yesterday and after all the F
the hoopla and all of that [__] I got
like a minute and a half in the game and
they already
scored I just like oh man I think the
final was 5 to one so congratulations to
you [__]
but um oh I got to fix my cooler too my
cooler took a beating both hinges were
broken as the interior strap thank
thankfully uh Igloo makes a repair kit I
you know it's obviously an easy repair I
got to get that [__] taken care of
this week uh that that [__] cooler
has been to every Rose Bowl I got to fix
it up here who knows maybe when I fell
I'm the one who knocked the [__] lid
off the thing all right breakfast here
we
go there's no way I did 45 minutes Jesus
Christ it's flying by all right
breakfast Bill I'm a father of two young
children and I hold a 9 to-5 corporate
job don't feel bad for me though I love
my job that's awesome I want you to love
your job and he goes and I don't [__]
about how hard it is to be a parent uh
he goes I maintain a decent diet I was a
college athlete so I have a basic
understanding of the human body granted
you and I spend our mornings differently
I freeze my ass off every morning for 5
to six months of the year
uh I was wondering what you do for
breakfast every
morning I don't what do you mean you
freeze your ass off what do you do all
right you're okay I I'm wondering what
you do for breakfast any every morning
and then he goes on to say I'm always on
the go and I'm not hungry right when I
leave for work uh which leaves me in the
car and at the office for the rest of
the morning not a lot of
options uh Beyond a banana and a coffee
it's too cold for smoothies what's aanda
do what's your morning food routine
well when I'm being smart I have two
eggs over easy and I have some oatmeal
with uh a banana and maybe some
blueberries I don't have any
uh bread or any of that stuff and then
between breakfast and lunch I have an
apple and then for lunch I have turkey
slices with the side
salad and then at uh 4:00 I have a meat
with a protein and 6:00 meat with a
protein and uh meat with the protein I
have a protein with vegetables dude what
the
[__] my brain is shot here I have yeah I
have a protein with some vegetables I
have meat with a protein and then I have
uh bread with some
carbs um that's what I end up doing and
then I just I stop eating around 6 5 6
is when I have my last meal and then I
just drink Waters after that if I get
really hungry I just have celery with
peanut butter and I got to get back to
that diet because I've been cooking up a
[__] store bakon and all that type of
stuff um and I have three goals this
month I'm going to make a kiche I'm
going to make a [__]
lasagna and I'm going to make this
huness chicken the last two are Mario
Batali recipes and uh the huness chicken
isn't that bad the [__]
[Music]
um the uh lasagna is pretty bad but
there's ve in it and I just can't I
can't get myself to eat lobster or ve I
just just what the [__] they go through
I mean I know the chickens and already
have a bad enough thing but like it just
seems extra [__] cruel boiling
something alive and and having something
just sit in a [__] cage forever so
it's softer and tastes better when you
eat it's just it's [__]
brutal
um
anyways all right so what's my morning
routine yeah if I was you and I had to I
would E I would get up I would make the
time and I would at least just have some
oatmeal
um I me but I don't have kids I mean I
just hearing you guys talking about
having kids makes me glad I don't have
any I mean it just seems so
[__]
um just never ending never ending
um I don't know so I will I will what do
you do for breakfast all right I told
you what I did the whole day
um yeah if I was I you have to make the
time I would definitely say that you got
to make the time and uh I think the best
thing for working out is you do it in
the morning and you just get it out of
the way and then you have a healthy
breakfast and that gets you on the right
track to start the day to start off the
day if you're eating bad and then try to
be like well don't worry I'm going to go
to the gym later the problem is with bad
food is it chemically [__] your body
and it makes you just want to lay down
and do nothing so uh if you start the
day I don't know just do that that the
tens remember I was telling you guys
about the
T to start off with was like uh 10
jumping jacks 10 burpees 10 push-ups 10
alternating lunges 10 sit-ups I forget
the [__] order I haven't done it but
you can you can look it up on the
internet and find it and
uh and you go from 10 and then you do
nine jump Jacks nine burpees nine
push-ups nine sit-ups nine alternate leg
jumps nine squat jumps and then you do
eight you go all the way down to one and
then you you know you're pretty much
winded and then if you want to add a
little more cardio to it skip skip rope
for a round or two or three or whatever
you want to [__] do uh you can do
that workout in like a hotel room
um but that's what I would do I would do
something like that and I would just
make sure you know also if you really
don't have time to work out what'll
really help you during the day is to
bring an apple and to pack a healthy
lunch also saves you money it also gives
you more of a lunch hour cuz you're not
driving to and from wherever the [__]
you're going you go right down to the
cafeteria you knock it out you chill the
[__] out you know
you have something healthy in your
afternoon break and that's the biggest
thing dude if you're not putting
mistakes into your [__] mouth you're
going to get more results from your
workout and you you know your clothes
will start fitting better and the same
way you get addicted to eating bad salt
sugar salt sugar you can get addicted to
eating well um which where is not where
I'm at right now um all right one trick
pony uh hey Billy
balls uh my wife loved your pie crust
video oh by the way you know I tried lot
in my um for my crust for the first time
and it was a total Game Changer the best
crust I ever made it did feel weird to
smell bacon as I was making the pie
crust but
um um uh thank you to everybody that
suggested that who you know the your
critique really helped my pie crust
thank you um all right so anyways he
this person says she's a fan of yours as
well she L the pie crust video she's a
fan of your as well and has been exposed
to hours of your podcast she likes you
Bill let me lead with that well here
comes the big [__] slap in the face
but of course like all great women she
still has a capacity to chop a man down
at the knees after the video I casually
said can't wait for the next one she
responded in an oh sweetie tone with
haha well how many of these tricks do
you think he has up his sleeve this
resulted in a long discussion where I
defended your potential skills and she
went with the I love Bill Burr I'm just
assuming he doesn't have much more to
rival this pie
crust uh whether you can make a full
series out of these videos or not can
you please explain to my wife that
you're not a one-trick pony and even if
you are a one-trick pony it's [__]
and unfair to assume this much uh thanks
come back to Wisconsin home of
corruption as seen in documentaries um
well you know something as you get older
as a man you understand where that's
coming from why your wife as you said
like all great women always have to take
you out of the knees what it is as much
as you got to stop internalizing that
and taking it personally what it is is
that's it's almost like a subconscious
fear thing that they have you know what
I mean like when they don't know you and
they see you doing something they have a
positive reaction ction to it going oh
look he can make a pie crust I bet he's
going to be a great dad right they think
[__] like that but after they get with
you and then they love you and they
don't want to lose you when they see you
continuing to grow as a person they it's
I can't even say this is a female thing
this is like a a thing in general that
people do in
relationships is you actually hold back
the person you love because you see them
expanding on who they are and because
it's something new new and different and
moves in a different direction I think
subconsciously a certain type of person
feels insecure so then they they have to
tether it to the ground with [__] uh
criticism rather than encouraging the
person so I think that that's where it's
coming from but
um as far as addressing
it
like I would just say this as far as my
cooking and baking like you don't just
know how to make corn flakes and you can
also make a pie crust you know what I
mean knowing how to make a pie crust
takes all of your [__] to the next
level okay like no like know this
because I can do that like back in the
day I used to look at like making like a
kiche or something like that going oh my
God that's [__] impossible the crust
alone or making a turkey pot pie or
anything that involves having a
crust um you can add that I recently
have learned how to smoke meat you know
I smoked
ribs uh
uh I can make all of my my my mother
before we when we all moved out she
wrote out all of her
recipes Han wrote them all out on cards
and we have all of them and we can all
cook the meals that she made when we
were growing up like I can make you
Hungarian
goulash and you know what else I can
make the [__] noodles from scratch I
took a pasta making class you know as
you suspected sir your wife has no idea
what the [__] she's talking about what
it really was it was coming from a place
of insecurity and jealousy and right now
she's going to roll her eyes and be like
oh my God blah blah blah blah it's
[__] true you know cuz that's really
just like a just like to have like that
that oh sweetie tone you know how they
do that [__] you know you go out you
start looking a little too good you get
a new new suit right you're looking a
little they got to [__] they got to
got to make a comment they they [__]
do it with each other it's larious I
think that's one of the main reasons
that's [__] them up by the way you
know when they always talk about the
wage Gap and all that one of the biggest
problems with the wage Gap is not men
it's the fact that women don't get
together and create businesses enough
they just don't do it CU they're too
busy going look at this [__] and
[__] look at her with she's too
[__] skinny she needs to eat
something she's got on too much [__] oh
she knows what she's doing you know they
don't work well together I don't know
why but that's not our fault I'm sure it
is though if you watch the vi I'm sure
they could spin it around to us so um
yes sir I actually
absolutely love cooking and um it isn't
the only trick I have up my
sleeve um I could obviously make more of
those but the thing about it was was
that was a specific skill it was for the
holidays and people have suggested well
why don't you do one on how to smoke
meat or why don't you do one about
making pasta from scratch my thing is
because you could watch Mario Batali do
it you can watch Champion smokers do it
so I guess what makes mine different is
that I make it
funny you know I just looked at it as a
a one [__] random thing that I was
going to do but you know now that she's
been a douche about it you know what
I'll make another one at some point I
guess I'm I'll let's see what the [__]
will I
do the turkey pot
pie on the Big Green Egg I mean I've
watched YouTube videos of all of those I
just didn't really saw somebody do like
a is there a pie crust video I don't
know I just thought it'd be fun I
literally feel like I'm in a
relationship right now I'm sorry that
that video annoyed
you oh God they're so [__] Moody U
yeah I will I will figure out something
else um to make one of those I'll do
like one a
year now it's actually G me some ideas
like maybe I'll do one ah the summer is
coming all right you're going to show up
the 4th of July is a quick [__] thing
you can make you know maybe I'll do it
maybe I'll do it I just don't like
committing to [__] like that I love not
having a job which is why I'm a [__]
comedian I I really enjoy this whole I
work when I want to rather than be okay
we need 20 episodes of this all right
Thursday afternoon podcast got me laid
Bill oh something
positive oh John do you really think you
could get somebody else laid it's
[__] disease um probably why we die 8
years earlier just because they just
won't give it up but if you get yourself
out in front of it next time your wife
does that to you sir next time she takes
you out at the knees just come up to her
and stroke the side of her face you know
when you go out and get a new car and
you oh honey don't you think you're a
little bit old for that car you know
does one of those things makes you feel
stupid right just walk up stroke the
side of her face like oh
sweetie don't worry I'm not going to
leave you
it's okay sh it's okay I know I look
good in the car I'm sorry something like
that something creepy all right Bill
last week on New Year's Eve my wife and
I listened to your podcast after we put
the kids to bed we drank wine and
laughed our asses off that's great this
woke us up energized us just as the
throwback clip came on it appeared that
we may have sex to ring in the New Year
well boy oh boy not more than a few
notes into the outro song we were going
at it it was all over just moments after
the song ended so maybe 4 minutes or so
of ball dropping Bliss my dick thanks
you for the laughs and the soundtrack
did you guys [__] to the Mundi song I
don't think I needed to know that um all
right oh here it
is here it is this is the one I wanted
to
read this is this is amazing
overpopulation
myth Bill how you're doing and I'm just
checking in on you uh to inform you that
if you go online and see for yourself
how
much arable a a b e farmland and
resources there actually is in the world
you'll see that there is enough to feed
and home at least 100 billion people for
approvable
fact I don't know that sentence didn't
make sense
did you like voice text this or did you
actually this is how you actually type
out sentences person goes so anytime you
hear anyone say that 7 billion people is
too many
people um
there th
he either seriously misinformed and or
too lazy to do some research or flat out
lying through their teeth like our
so-called leaders and scientists must be
oh yeah they got to be lying because you
not you can't even spell there
right because within one to do two days
of research you can find studies that
prove what I said it's going to take me
one to two days to find it on the
internet this is [__] hilarious one
two days one to two days research you
can find studies that prove what I say
is true parentheses at least 100 billion
now I know you're in the
business
of
waking the masses up just like the late
great Bill Hicks no I'm not but do you
realize how serious the situation is
regarding the distraction and
brainwashing as organized by big
business and their controlling family
owners so as great as I think you and
your comedy are mentioning
overpopulation which is a complete myth
is doing them parentheses big
corporations and the cuns who own them a
big service in adding to the
brainwashing anyway Bill I know you're a
great man because of the subject you
talk about during your shows but please
look for yourself at how much admir
adorable Farmland there is and consider
the fact that all food grows completely
for
free um wow all right well I'll tell you
this buddy I know I'm a [__] so I just
looked up I looked this how many people
can the Earth
sustain
um and it says uh how many people can
the earth support so 10 billion people
is the utmost population limit where
food is concerned that's the first one
the next one says more than 7 billion
people currently on the planet compared
to 3 billion in
1967 that one doesn't
say I I'll just well that's a video I
don't want to watch
that current population is three times
the sustainable
level that's uh the next
article uh um how many people can the
Earth sustain I'll click on this one I'm
trying to find anything that says
anything even remotely close to 100
Milli 100 billion here's a stagnant stat
according to the United Nations the
world's current population is 7.2
billion it's now up to 7.8 is projected
to increase by 1 billion over the next
12 years which would bring us to 9.6
billion by
2050 how can we sustain all these people
on the planet or rather how many people
can this planet sustain that is the
question Alan Weiss been explored in his
latest book countdown our last best hope
for a future on Earth question
mark um Jesus Christ a bunch of
conversations bunch of words how about a
number where is the [__]
number all right he has the chart or how
it's going to the next 50 years we will
need to produce as much food as ever
been consumed for an entire human
history well that makes sense cuz
they'll be the most people they'll be
the most farts ever in the history of
human
beings well there's no [__] number
there sir all I can tell you is is if
you see the environmental damage that
7.8 billion people did if you're going
to have 100 billion people
like I mean at this point in Africa
there's barely any land for for wild
animals it's all it's all like for the
most part down in the southern part of
of the country uh
it's all like roped
off it's finite you know what I mean
they're completely
surrounded I'd have to say that I
disagree and not just by your spelling
cuz I couldn't read half the [__]
words you said even when you spelled
them right but yeah no there's no
[__] way 100 billion
people and there's any sort of animal
life left that isn't stuck in a
cage you know what I mean um and also in
this last year I traveled to Singapore
Hong Kong and Mumbai India and I saw
what that next level of population
looked like dude and I was breathing
that air not Singapore Singapore was was
different um but Hong Kong and Mumbai
India you could almost taste the [__]
air and it was just
uh it was just way too many [__]
people I can I can tell you that there's
no way 100 million people
um and I don't understand why I need to
look it up for one to two days why
couldn't you just send me a link I would
love for you to be right but uh I'm
going to go out on limb and say you're
not I'm going to go with the scientist
on this one and also this also sounds
like you know when people denied global
warming not to get all political but one
political party adamantly denied it for
years and years and years and now they
decades and now they finally just go
yeah we are causing climate change but
you know what it's too late
now so I imagine that that's what we're
going to do out here we have a [__]
methane gas leak that's been going on
and I guess that's Pro it's like 10
times worse than carbon dioxide as far
as getting put into the [__] uh
atmosphere as far as heating it up and
all that we're completely [__] we're
[__] we're absolutely [__] um and
selfishly I hope I it doesn't happen by
the end of my own life which is the
exact sort of thought process that got
us into this mess to begin with but sir
you're you're correct in assuming that
I'm a [__] dope and I don't know what
I'm talking about but
uh I'm just kind of going with having
traveled
extensively you know for the last 20
years on the road and watching the
population increase just in this
country
um it's a weird thing when the
population it keeps looking like it's
sort of leveled
off and I don't know if because there's
no factories anymore all I know is like
I've I it used to be back in the day if
I jumped on the highway at 2:00 in the
afternoon I was good and now everywhere
I go there's like traffic and I'm just
looking at these people going like are
you guys all standup Comics does
everybody work the third shift how the
[__] are all these people out on the
road I don't know what's going on do a
lot of people work from home and they're
all driving out to get a sandwich at
that time I don't know you know what let
me look up the I heard the US population
is kind of leveled off which has excited
me that's exciting to me you
know US
population
Jesus Christ Bill can you [__]
population by year let's do this all
right let's see what we got here US
population by
year uh right let's go back to
1997 there was
27265 million and now there's
322.058 million
is that enough to notice well that's
actually you know that's significant
right that's like an 20% increase I
think I making some
points all right let's move on here all
right uh advice changing high
schools dear Bill I'm a freshman in high
school and would like to know your
perspective on my situation I currently
attended a performing arts high school
and major in jazz studies that's [__]
cool I enjoy it and all but this uh the
first semester has passed I found out
that jazz is something I don't want to
do in life rather than carry on for with
the next 3 years of this major I'd
rather change schools and major
something that would benefit me in the
long run especially if I want to attend
big schools like Harvard uh well that's
good man you tried something you you've
realized early on you don't like it and
you got enough strength to be like I to
communicate it I don't want to do this
and you'll need something else it's all
good so far uh the problem is that in
leaving my current school I could
possibly devastate the bands I'm in oh
Jesus there came an ego out of nowhere
and also hurt some friends my director
has placed me in some good bands and I
even get paid money for playing G I'll
see you crushing it I would Phil CH to
leave my director as he has put me in a
position that many others would gladly
take this question has been tearing me
apart for a while what do you think Bill
should I stay or should I go also so if
I do decide to leave do you think I
should tell my friends and directors
that I that I am or should I just go out
quietly um dude you have to do in life
if what makes you happy if you try to
make other people happy that's all
you're going to do and you're not going
to be happy and then you're going to be
miserable to be around you're going to
turn into a bitter person who didn't do
what they wanted to do in life and no
one wants to be around that guy all
right so as much as it's going to hurt
them uh you got to leave and you got to
tell them and you have to tell them why
you're going to leave and just say
listen I'm just not happy doing this I
understand that I'm lucky and that a lot
of people would kill to be in my
position so I feel that someone should
at least be happy and be
excited you know if people desire to be
in my position and I'm occupying that
position and I'm not happy I'm doing an
injustice to myself and one of you guys
all right I apologize I'm sorry and then
that's it and you know what it's a great
life lesson sometimes you know when you
ask for what you want people get hurt
and uh you know I don't mean you
physically have to hurt him you know
their bottom lip Quivers a little bit
that's all I'm saying um that's it but
don't go out quietly don't sneak out the
back door be a man or woman man about it
and [__] you know be an adult all
right that's it and you should be
commended for understanding that you
don't like
something and and not just staying in it
all right book recommendations all right
hey
Bill um not just start off by blowing
smoke up your ass but f f is for family
is a phenomenal show has me cracking up
non-stop but I digress well thank you I
appreciate that gives me a chance to
promote the show uh if you haven't
watched it yet please check out fers for
family evidently we're doing great on
the old Netflix
there uh this person says I remember you
mentioned you
read open oh that you read open by Andre
augusty so I picked it up and started
reading it it truly is one of the books
that's tough to put down was wondering
if you had any other recommendations
that you've read of late thanks and go
[__] yourself uh that comedian book that
I mentioned um I have it
downstairs uh it's like the history of
uh standup comedy let me look it up here
um which is taking me forever to get
through cuz every time they bring up a
name I'm like who the [__] is that guy
and then I look him up and then I'm on
the internet but it's been a it's been a
joy history of
standup
comedy
book
there it is all right this is what I've
been reading it's called The
Comedians uh drunks thieves Scoundrels
in the history of American Comedy Jesus
Christ how about Brilliance do you know
any Geniuses in there no not no nod to
Prior Lenny Bruce none of that all
right um yeah so I would that's what
I've been reading and uh I don't know
I'm in another one of those modes where
I'm just playing a lot of drums and I'm
I'm cooking and that type of stuff and
uh also feeling the pressure to put out
another cooking video to shut up
somebody that I never met before how
[__] ridiculous is that um I should
just let it go you know I should but you
know what I'm not going to you know what
maybe I'll make a [__] I'll make a
breakfast one I made a pie one I'll make
a breakfast one I'll make a lunch one
I'll make a dinner or a supper one I'll
do it over throughout the [__] years
all right that'll be all basic cooking
by a basic [__] all right that's the
podcast for this week go [__] yourselves
I'll check in on you on
Thursday um It's a Brand New Year I have
like two standup gigs booked because I'm
trying to figure out what the [__] is
going to go on with this show if we're
going to get a second season I I need to
know but uh I think I'm just going to
start booking
[__]
um cuz that's how this business works
you know if you uh if you book a bunch
of [__] then they just go oh well let's
[__] give you something right in the
middle of all that other [__] that you
booked if you don't book anything then
you're just going to be staring at your
phone and it's never going to
ring what are you [__] witch bill you
into you into superstitious stuff well
maybe I am I have no idea but uh Paul
verie is going to try to not
drink starting today until the beginning
of April and I told him that I would I'm
sort of half ass committed that I would
do it with
them um so I'm sort of on the wagon
right now I didn't drink last night
tonight I don't really have any desire
to do it today I'm [__] wiped out so
we'll see I'm going to try to see I I'll
try to go as long as I can um all right
that's it go [__] yourselves I'll talk
to you on
Thursday what's up everybody and welcome
back to the anything better podcast NFL
Edition for week 18 the final week of
the regular season is upon us and uh we
got a great last show for you Last picks
uh but don't worry the playoffs are
coming by the way before we get into
this I don't know if you guys
remember I I beat the book last year and
Paulie [__] the bed in the playoffs I
was like one and seven and the rest of
the show carried me so I want to bring
this winning streak into the playoffs
because oh paully had a rough one last
year but we got one more week I know but
you beat the book three years in a row
that I did and it was not a pile on team
wasn't a pile on you didn't need Kobe
sha Phil Jackson Kevin Garnett [__]
KD it was Paul Paul alone he did not
take his talents to South Beach he
stayed right there in New York you know
he wore a different hoodie for 18 weeks
in a row the man is not superstitious he
he beats the book you Paul
Bersy and you know what Bill death taxes
and Paul verie beating the bookie that's
[__] amazing Paul I was in uh I was
in um uh Los Angeles in my hotel week
three I went 0 and four I was like six
game under I was licking my wounds I was
licking my wounds but you know what
picture with your head between your
knees oh God this isn't me
man oh bill by the way you gonna jump
you uh I think you me and I don't know
what thess did but we both went three in
one you and
I you and I must go three in one I need
to go s and0 this week off of four games
to somehow break be 500 I accidentally
on the chart picked five games but I
they won the first four and then I
noticed that I told you guys whatever
happens I'll just I'll take one win off
so I went three three I'll give it three
in one all right okay so basically us
three collectively went nine and three
um but let's get into the sponsor before
uh we get into this guys you guys know
what it is it is the great B MGM the
best lines out there the best live lines
out there if you haven't signed up yet
get uh you get $1,500 [__] together your
first bet
offer it is four easy steps you download
the bmgm app you sign up using the bonus
code for our show the anything better
show which is Burr could not be easier b
r r and you are in all right all you got
to do is put at least $10 into the B MGM
Sportsbook account place your first
wager and receive up to $1,500 back in
bonus bet bets if the BET loses if the
BET does lose your bonus bets will be
available once your initial wager is
settled bet responsibly have fun let's
get into week 18 oh oh oh oh oh oh I
gotta I gotta tell you guys something
Bill you're gonna love this uh I wanted
to uh send this to
you but I couldn't yesterday but check
this out so unfortunately my back has
been really bad I have a disc issu is
issue and I'm going to get some X-rays
tomorrow and everything so I couldn't go
to my son's basketball game yesterday
which was home but they have a thing
where you could actually watch it with
the link they send you so I'm laying in
bed and I'm on my phone and they they do
it they actually do a good job they scan
the thing I see my daughter sitting down
in the bleachers I hear my wife talking
like right dude they're playing this
team West Lake which can you press a
button and like yell at the ref from
your house dude I wanted to the [__] was
that dude I wanted to no I wanted to
press a button and yell like guys hands
up def it was like I'm laying there
watching it right so anyway they're
playing I want throwing out another disc
oh dude so um they're playing a team
that's Superior to them they're playing
a team that they played already this
year and lost by 24 so Lucas Lucas had a
couple buddies over around New Year's
and he's going Dad we're gonna be closer
we're gonna play them closer long story
short I'm watching this thing it was
like a movie when the injured players at
a hospital bed jumping around dude I am
I'm watching this let's let's win this
one for my dad
yeah so um it's like a two or
three-point game then they start pulling
away they get up six in the fourth Lucas
hits a three then they hit another one
and then we're five it's a fivepoint
game like a minute something left
they're up or down what we're down H so
Lucas so
Lucas um he gets a steal
with like like two minutes left runs
down it's just him and the kid I'm
laying in bed he goes up N1 goes in the
place goes nuts what are you doing oh
dude I leaned up and I went
ah and I told I told Stacey I go Stacy I
just cheered and hurt myself I go ah
yeah right no you
yeah it hurt it hurts so great scene in
a movie dude so [__] hilarious oh so
he goes to the foul line just swishes
the foul shot they come down dude they
they they score again then he hits a
three dude and and now it's like a
two-point game and they get fouled and
they go to the line and miss both and we
don't get the
rebound and and everyone's going like
this box them out that that's what
they're screaming you got a box out so
we foul him again they go to the line
hit one now it's a three-point game they
call timeout they design a play for
Lucas to to shoot a three oh my God and
dude he comes up and he was really far
out he was really far out and St Curry
and he jumped too high and it rattles in
and out dude and then there's a there's
point seven seconds left we got the ball
because they tipped it out of bounds and
we threw it in and we lose at the buzzer
and he comes home we would have never
been in the game if it wasn't for him he
comes home and I knew what it was going
to be and he walks up the stairs and I
go hey buddy I saw every second of that
game great game and he just looks at me
and looks away he doesn't say nothing
and then Stacy goes did you hear your
father and he just keeps walking and I
hear his door
close and uh I go in his room and I'm
like hey man he's just got his head down
he goes do you have a walker he goes can
you please leave he goes can you can you
please leave leave right now and I just
tapped him on the leg I go buddy I go
dude those shots I go You Led You Know
What You Lead all scorers that steal you
had that you're not even in the game if
you don't do that you're not even in the
game you know and he's just like Dad can
you just please so I let him have his
thing and then he came out and he's
talking and he's
like he's like yeah I just uh I just
texted the coach and I said don't think
I don't want that shot every time or
something and then he just looked at me
he has a game today and he goes I can't
[__] wait to play again and I was
just like there it is dude there it is I
go you're going to have a lot of those
but uh I got I got some video for you to
see dude it's nuts man it's nuts Jesus
yeah yeah dude he's got the mentality
he's got the shot that's amazing no dude
it was it was nuts and I was like yeah
if if dude but it's almost better that
this if that shot went in I would have
fell off the bed and been flopping
around like a [__]
fish
uh it was amazing dude like he's gonna
win games for that team like he's just
like coming into his own so and also you
know what it is too it's like it's
incredible uh life experience the ups
and downs and then the stories you have
and then that Bond you have with your
friends that you know yeah I got friends
of mine to that that like there there's
still towns they drive through and they
get like this feeling because they lost
the game there you know I didn't play
organized Sports my parents thought I
was you know I would do I wouldn't do as
well in school so they pulled me out
organized Sports in uh the fifth grade
because I got a D in math and then I
proceeded to flunk everything anyway
they took away the one thing I would
have been halfway decent with but you
know they were academias I I couldn't
imagine somebody said like imagine these
parents that have multiple children in
the pros and they go and they see them
compete against each other and one's on
the [__] Jets and one's on the you
know Niners it's like I'm watching my
son play a team like in high school far
superior and I'm watching him bring the
gymnasium to life and make it a game
because of his shooting and it was dude
I was [__] how about the parents the
amount of hours yeah if your kid makes
it all the way to that level all the way
to the NFL the amount of hours that you
invested driving them to practice going
to all the
games it's unreal like and dude they and
you know what's nuts is watching them
double team him and hearing another
coach going like don't let him shoot I'm
just like it's the great dude dude
there's like three guys on him when he's
pulling up the [__] best um all right
bill it is week
18 it is week 18 we both went three in
one last week I believe it's my pick
first and I am gonna go I don't even
[__]
care um no playing with house money here
Paul yeah but we like to close strong no
I want to close strong so we we we build
some sort of winning tradition here I'm
[__] I'm on Hot Seat Paul last two
years I haven't beat the
book let and here come the excuses go
going into this week just so people know
the records Bill you're 3031 and
four what I'm only a game down yeah dude
you went three and one two and two yeah
you're 30 I'm I'll re add everything up
it's all right well
[__] uh Paul work man Paul you're 3625
and three that's a big [__] you to the
book what do you got Andrew Well despite
the fact I didn't actually make any
money gambling this year I did pretty
well in this particular area uh 4119 and
five what why aren't you hosting the
show CA because it's a fluke bill it's
well why don't you put money on the
games that you're [__] betting at
some point during the
season I I don't like individual you
know you got too much y Shucks in you
all right that's my one [__] thing
about you Andrew you're too goddamn
modest Andrew silent and then Jake The
Snake just [__] laying in the weeds
every week just [__] with his [__]
like like a like a [__] snake
paw just hitting the book and the book
has to take a nap like a mongoose
all right let's let's [__] do this
Paul all right my first pick I am going
to take a team that just needs to win
and they're in and they're at home and
that is the Green Bay Packers minus
three against the Bears if the Packers
win they make the playoffs they won last
week and um I think they're gonna I
think even though the Bears are playing
well I think the Packers find a way to
get into the playoffs I'm gonna take
Green Bay at home all right I like the
uh Cleveland Browns getting seven over
the Bengals at home
o I don't know if there's somebody hurt
I don't give a [__] I like the Browns
defense and I like getting
seven and I like coffee and I like
having eggs I like
lamp why are the Kansas City oh because
they clinched got it never
mind they clinched see this is the week
this is a weird week that's stupid they
should [__] play they should go out
and bury the Chargers make them think
about moving back to San Diego that's
what they should be doing I'm goingon to
take the Jacksonville Jaguars minus you
love the Jags I do love that pick minus
five and a half versus the Texans who I
think the Titans I mean the Titans which
I think Mike vel's gonna get I think
they're gonna can him I got a feeling I
gotta tell you something Paul that's a
great coach to pick up yeah he's good
he's really did great things there Paul
you know he they didn't have all the
money they didn't have all the guys that
guy's a winner I like Mike grael rough
black Monday for
Mikey no he that guy's definitely gonna
work again hey Mike the amount of guys
the amount of [__] chances some guy
I'm not gonna say the names Paul but the
amount of guys that just keep getting
chance after chance look at college
football Lane kein and now he finally
lands in Mississippi he's doing great
things he's doing great things I gotta
tell you something I gotta tell you
something somebody just said the Raiders
should pick up Vel Perfect Fit I would
stick with the guy they have yeah for
some reason they're saying they might
not which is weird
um oh G Paul throw a throw a guess out
throw a guess in there no no they W they
AR shell they had the first black coach
yeah they coach they did what do you
think of coaches doing with their wives
after the last
Sunday honey don't answer the
phone and then they go that's great
let's do a little stay vacation I'm not
going anywhere oh you know what sweetie
they want to just maybe say good job see
you next year n give me my box bring
that empty
box Karen pack up we're moving where I
don't know
yet we should have gone for
two can't make me laugh Bo you're back
sorry although that is tempting to keep
making you laugh oh that's funny we
should have went for two we should have
picked up that kicker he always is left
goe what you all right the lions got
[__] last week they need to win they
need to go in positive they don't need
to win but I this are these guys all
gonna puss out the last week and rest
their
starters um is that what they're all
gonna do these are all division rivalry
games the NFL's setting it up for
exciting games and then Patrick
Mahomes is going to sit out this week is
that what he's only going to play a half
Bo what's going on here yeah they're
probably like play play
halfs so St all right whatever I you
know I don't give Paul all I can go with
is what I know I like the Lions minus
three and a half versus the Minnesota
Vikings um I like that I like that I
like what's that coaches Dan Campbell
yep I like that guy I was saying on my
podcast he was like when he just kept
going for two against the Cowboys he was
like Joe peshy when he was playing
Blackjack and
casino hey take that ineligible and
shove it up your mother's
ass just keeps going he was on that ow
and 16 team pole he's like not again
[__] I like this guy players
coach I like him and I like what's the
guy in the Raiders name Antonio Pierce
Antonio Pierce those guys look like
football guys they look they don't look
like analytic
guys Rona done their [__] throats
Paul like smile how can you
smile um all right here we go 49ers and
Rams oh my darling Oh My Darling Oh My
Darling 49ers I don't know dude we're
gonna sit prie and we're gonna sit
somebody else and then the Rams are
gonna win but two no they're at the
49ers you ever see that Stadium Paul
looks like a [__] roller coaster when
you're walking up to it I'm gonna take
oh when the saints come marching in
Marching In
Saints
Go it beat the Falcons by more than
[__]
three backs gonna feel much better I
think the Saints are going to win that
game by three because I believe they
have a shot they might need help but if
they win they got a shot so I'm gonna
take the Saints at home minus three
against the division rival you know be
hilarious is if the Saints release Derek
Carr and the Patriots pick him up so we
all go dude [__]
Derek
I'm going to take the commanders plus 13
versus the Cowboys that's a great bet
that's great division rivalry evidently
everybody's going to sit down this week
to pee you know going into the [__]
playoffs all right I'll do
that and four my fourth and final pick
of this
season my last pick of this
year's
thing I'm gonna finish off with my New
York Giants getting four and a half in
Philadelphia what is going on in Philly
Paul Philadelphia is reeling they just
lost to the Cardinals and I know the
Giants are going to try to give them a
little [__] you before it's over not
saying the Giants win the game it had to
be it had to be injuries Paul what
happened to them I don't know but I like
the four and a half I like the four and
a half so oh Paulie cutlets oh paully
pasta he's sticking with his Pon over
there he's benched they benched Tommy's
been benched oh Tommy got benched two
weeks ago I'll tell you something there
is no City in the sport world that can
get you [__] excited about someone
that's going to be on the bench two
[__] weeks later or traded 100
per. never seen anything like it Mark
Sanchez I mean they started Tommy
cutlets who the Asian kid just killing
everybody on the Knicks who was that kid
uh Jeremy Lynn oh my God why did you
trade that
guy he was a New York City Legend and
then they we're gonna trade you to
Houston who you who'd you get for him h
d I don't even know we just [__]
Craig Gatlin Chris Gatlin who' you get
for him I don't know who the [__] we
got well you have a fourth pick I do
have a fourth pick Paul and I'm taking
the Chicago Bears I'm going against you
Paul you know I love you all right you
know I love you and I you know I love
Jordan love you know that [__] kid's
got that arm dude I I I love the Packers
but it's just they're eight and eight
the Bears are coming on I don't know
it's a these [__] teams yeah they
played each other a zillion times I'm
starting to believe in that Ohio State
kid on the Bears I think everybody just
shut the [__] up and they're just
letting them sling it and I like what
they're doing over there Paul and I'm a
standup comedian so what the [__] do I
know there you go that
completes Paul I swear to God I need I
can't I cannot go two and two I have to
go three and
one Paul I need this
one
let's get all desperate Paul you don't
understand dude you were you I've never
seen a guy say they weren't doing you
were like two and two every week this
year um well the level that I had to
leave my [__] house watching the
Cowboys pissed that [__] game away to
the
lions that was the story not that this
[__] guy checked in Paul it was that
they were up by seven and the Lions had
only scored 13 points the whole whole
game and all of a sudden they first of
all they should have run the ball three
times before they kicked a field goal
they threw it one time I get it they
went for the [__] kill shot but you
missed that thing you you saved 30
seconds you just gave them a [__]
timeout they run the ball on third down
they line up they kick the [__] ball
then they go into this soft Zone 15 yard
prevent dude they just show their
bellies dude it's 10 yards for a first
down now I'm an old guy I don't remember
does this does the clock stop on a first
down inside two minutes I think it does
it does it's so you're giving him
timeout timeout timeout yeah 25 yards 10
yards 14 yards Paul you want to know why
I don't have any [__] hair it's the
prevent defense dude I gotta no but you
know something I think dude Mike
McCarthy that coach that's why they
hated him in the Packers do you know how
many games they were winning late in
playoff games and then all of a sudden
they just [__] play scared the
Cowboys [__] sucked at the end of
that game they they didn't suck the the
the the the [__] idea to to do that
soft Zone
sucks yeah I want to see the analytics
on that Paul like how many times does it
actually run out the clock because all I
think it all thing I think it does is it
guarantees an exciting ending for
football fans and that they're the other
team that's down is going to get four
shots at the end zone yeah but you
notice that the 49ers don't do that some
of those these really good teams don't
Alabama Crimson Tide does not do that if
you watch that Auburn game when Auburn
[__] pulled their pants down and bent
over the [__] goddamn couch rushan
two and the [__] guys just standing
back there granted it was an incredible
throw incredible throw but they scor the
touchdown the very next one they got him
pinned down on the two yard line and
they given him a 15 yard cushion Sabin
got him up on the [__] line yeah
playing football Paul you play to win
the games you know why because the
defensive coach are going no one's
beating us deep that's what happens dude
on a two-minute Drive they go nobody's
beating us deep get back get back it's
you haven't beat you deep all day at
what point are you going to believe that
the first 58 minutes were true exactly
right that's why you know what me and
you should just quit com let's just
coach a team me and you I'll be your D
coordinator this is us at the end of the
season I have a new found respect for
coaching uh there was a lot of things I
didn't take into consideration when I
was sitting on my couch
H there has to be a reason Paul about
club soda Kenny being a coach you're
out Kenny doesn't give a [__] about
sports he's been to a bunch of sporting
events with me and when he goes he's
immediately breaking down the game yeah
he goes why do they keep running that
play I was like this guy's like paying
attention he can't shut it off Paul he's
immediately he just like he's like a
[__] security camera just looking at
the offense and defensive side why do
they why do they keep doing this he
shouldn't be single covered Mister
double
him are they gonna cover that guy how
many buckets is he going to score and
you're just looking at him like and I go
like look at you and then he just laughs
I go but you still don't give a [__]
he's like
no I'll tell you Paul I don't miss being
on the road because I love my children
and my wife so much I [__] love being
home but the only thing that sucks about
being home is [__] club soda Kenny
I don't get to see him as much dude I
know he's dude that that guy Heart of
Gold loyal as they come yeah he's he's
he's the greatest Paul like that's one
of those guys when he [__] retires
there's that you you don't replace him
no you just tell the stories and I love
that when we were at the Masters with
him he was so psyched to see tiger when
we were psyched he was like there he
like he knew like he knows you know he
loved it he loved it you know what he's
into on the road presidential
libraries he gets into the Secret
Service and [__] so we were supposed to
start hitting those things oh that's um
dude the two funniest presidential
libraries ever is gonna have to be Trump
and
Biden you know what I
mean like the Trump one should be like
part amusement park because he's so
[__] if he's not running the country
the guy is [__] hilarious um and then
Joe Biden I don't know what it is you
you know what it should be you you they
don't really build it your Goog Google
Maps can't find it or something like
some there's something about like I
don't remember Jake Jake just wrote
George W bush is very funny there's a
whole wing of him throwing out the first
pitch by the way I didn't know that
Jeter story I didn't know that Jeter
story and Jeter just told the story when
George W bush went out to throw the
first pitch in N after 911 and this is
before he bankrupted the country with
his damn good intelligence right yeah
uh he uh he goes uh Jeter goes you're
throwing out the first pitch he's said
yeah and he goes you throwing it from
the mound or the front of the mound and
Bush goes I'm gonna throw it from the I
was gonna throw it from the front of the
mountain and Jeter goes they they're
gonna boo you they're gonna boo you and
he goes you got to go to the mountain so
then B bush is like all right I'll go to
the Mount so then he goes to the Mount
he said and as he's walking away Jeter
just goes don't bounce it they'll boo
you too can I tell you something Paul is
there any there's no better fans than
[__] East Coast Fans
I mean that's a fact I mean I mean the
fact that you guys you're going to boo
the president not on any political basis
is because he's being a [__] and
throwing it from the front
of I mean as a Red Sox fan I mean that's
[__] great I I 100% I am behind that
um oh by the way dude did you see the
[__] dude I was up last night I have
to sleep in another room another
mattress cuz my mattress is bad for my
back right now so so I'm watching this
thing I'm crying laughing punching the
thing oh God did you see the dude jump
over the bench when the judge so there
was a judge in Nevada this woman and you
just see split screen and the dude's
just like this and she goes well yeah I
appreciate that but you know you have
too many felon you have too many things
you're gonna have to and this dude just
goes man shut up [__] dude he runs as
fast as he can from behind the where he
was sitting with his lawyer Bill the air
he got he Dove over the bench his legs
were so high he he Dove over and
sideways it was like a wrestler and he
grabbed the [__] woman throws her
down the bayts are stopping him and
everything and then there was there was
a meme somebody made a video of trump
holding a football going like this and
then throwing it and then the guy
jumping over Dude I [__] lost control
of myself but yeah he jumped dude that
guy's gonna get like 30 dude he no he
already was done he didn't jump dude he
[__] it was like he turned into
Superman it was the craziest [__] I'll
send you he threw a uh the the the a
body block dude he looked like Jimmy
Superfly snooker off the ropes but and
he made it over you know it would be
great if she caught him and then just
Tony Atlas him and [__] over the
bench slammed him no like did the spin
around and everybody in the court like
yeah she put up like hul Hogan and then
[__] gives him the [__] what is it
the people's elbow oh [__] dude um all
right Bill we got one dude if that
happens again you're going to see judges
are going to start looking like bank
tellers oh I dude the level of air was
so I can't believe how high he got
um sh all the way around man throwing
your life away doing that [__] the
[__] and then her getting hit that's
that's a goddamn shame not saying it's
not hilarious listen I hope the lady's
fine but it was one of the most
hilarious things I've ever witnessed on
the internet I also have to give a shout
out to the general public Paul
like they just keep getting funnier and
funnier like the general public before
the internet was water cooler jokes you
know what I mean and then occasionally a
person you see you could be a stand-up
comedian dude like my favorite thing
Instagram is the the the the comments I
saw this band everybody in the band was
obese and I immediately went to the
comments and everybody was naming the
band I mean they were brilliant Judas
Feast might depes Alam
mode
Jimmy 8world was my favorite
one I was just sitting there by myself a
stand up comic I don't laugh at [__] I
had tears rolling down my eyes going
this is [__] this is amazing so shout
out to regular people man they're
[__] hilarious in in the Judi Feast
Judi
Feast theala mode oh my god oh dude and
and that's that's only the ones I could
remember it was just they just kept
going and going going and then sometimes
people would actually name real bands
that had food like cake remember that
band oh yeah yeah yeah he's going the
distance oh my God that's [__] he's
going for speed Paul uh we missed you on
the tailgate like oh man I'm gon I'm
gonna tell you I sent you that video
when I sat down with that [__]
perfect bacon egg and cheese on an
English mushin made on the Flatt top
grill by Mike bertolina and I had the
last cappuccino and I was just sitting
there on a dude people were coming over
to our tailgate going like wow you guys
you guys got coffee you got flat top
girl what what what is this thing called
here dude I got the ratchet straps I
thought I was gonna be like losing my
[__] trying to figure out because I'm
I'm really bad at [__] like that like I
don't know why I just I like to me the
back of the stove is the front of the
stove like I don't know how my brain is
wired but I always look at the stove
like I'm standing behind a car in
traffic so I I was able to figure that
out and uh it didn't move even a
hair like I was driving so like gingerly
no pun intended and I was just thinking
like you know I put all of this [__] in
here you know I'm afraid stuff's gonna
go flying to we we even had an extra
[__] uh tank for the uh for the flat
top in case it ran out or if somebody
else needed it and how about the game
not only did you have a great tailgate
how about gets even better the tailgate
down from us one of the former nose
tackles from the I saw this guy was
[__]
huge and uh they came over with shooting
the [__] he was on the 97 team I think
that won the National Championship
that's the last time they won it so how
great Paul Michigan verse Washington hey
uh Jake The Snake can you can you look
up when was last time the Washington
Huskies won a a championship I don't
think in my lifetime they ever won one
that I can remember I used to remember
they went to the Rose Bowl a lot when I
was a kid was it
maybe there he
is take it's got the Scruff going you
got a lady in your life you're on the
prow what's going on with
you I like the new [__] uh sex symbol
Jake going into the
playoffs y got gotta get ready U let's
see last time they won a championship
they
have um
1991 they won at
91 yes I'm looking up some more details
well there you go shows you what the
[__] I know about sports they went 12
and0 who who is their quarterback was
that Drew BL no Drew blo was Washington
State um good question let's see third
quarterback was that the other guy that
people drafted it looks like Mark
brenell
was Mark brell great quarterback for the
Jackson uh for the Jacksonville Jags
yeah yeah uh and who was their
coach Tom Coughlin yeah Tom Coughlin
um dude I'm I am a Trevor Lawrence fan I
am a Trevor Lawrence fan too I am a
[__] fan watching that guy shake off
that injury seeing how bad he wants to
win and I was calling him the
good-looking zombie I don't think it's
that I think he's the [__] Terminator
man I I I'm I didn't not I didn't read
that look in his eye
properly look let's be honest he's a
[__] greatl looking guy with
Incredible head of hair I got a little
jealous Paul I got in my feelings you
know um I don't think any sport show
that exists has more wins against the
number against the book than our
show do you know
that that's I think that's a I've W
there's I mean unless there's a show out
there that I don't know about but
nobody's going against the book this
many games why you going shook Knight on
us right now Paul no dancing in the
videos I just want to say all up in all
your
[__] uh come to death row for your picks
all right Bill we have one last special
and it is the special we have is wait
wait wait before we go Paul who do you
like Michigan or the Huskies I heard the
Huskies have a great coach I like
Michigan because Michigan showed me that
Michigan showed me during that Alabama
game dude if if that team was ever gonna
give it up it would have been to Alabama
in that game and they didn't that
running back is an absolute animal that
quarterback played Good Under Pressure
they played sloppy though and they made
a lot of mistakes so I'm hoping that
that was uh unforced [__] errors that
that thing with the hand off the ball
and then he goes to throw it back to him
it doesn't make it to the quarterback he
falls on it I dud the whole time I was
like that's it you do that once against
Nick Saban it's [__] over here's why
I think Michigan wins because when I
watch Michigan's defensive line get that
kid in the back field a lot especially
that number 55 the big strong thing for
the Washington um Huskies is their
quarterback Mike panx Jr and I think if
you get to that kid I think that
Washington will lose the game and I
think Michigan smells it and I think
they're going to get it so my pick is
Miss yeah that kid that kid I only
watched him for uh like the last 3 four
minutes of the game and then I kind of
read up on him in battling back from two
ACL injuries I think that that guy is a
killer yeah uh I think it's a pick them
I think the only reason why it's a minus
four is because Vegas tries to get money
on both
sides um I'm excited for both programs
because they haven't won in a long time
but as a Michigan fan this would be
crushing to come this close but I would
on the other side be very excited that
Washington won because uh you know
everybody deserves 30 years to get one
huh like you said though you made a good
point Michigan made stupid play like
Mich the fumble on the one when that kid
could have got that could have been
[__] I think they're going to clean
that up the interception to start the
game for he threw it right to him he was
trying to throw it out of bounds they
the fumbled punt the [__] when he
threw it back to him they just they just
kept making these stupid [__] I don't
think yeah I don't think they're going
to do that this time I think they're GNA
clean and they were good enough to beat
Alabama with those [__] mistakes how
many times has Nick sa been capitalized
on those mistakes on another team yeah I
think that this was the first time in a
while that he didn't seamlessly
transition from losing his senior class
into bringing or some Juniors and
seniors into like another amazing the
guy's recruitment is on a whole other
level and I know people oh they're
[__] crooked and blah the whole
[__] thing is crooked okay so he's
playing the game you know better than
everybody else so I mean that's just uh
and give reg his [__] Heisman Trophy
already you see this kid these kids are
[__] in pen houses and Ferraris right
now because it's legal now [__] give
okay well and also Reggie Bush was not
running the [__] program but I don't
give a [__] what they were doing he
still gained all of those yards he 100%
should have his his Heist trop [__] that
really is like I mean what did they take
away from Pete Caroll dude guess his
champion ship but they he he didn't have
to give up a [__] windbreaker right
and then they go after this kid and he
has to [__] give back the highest
trophy uh in sports give it back to him
they're like they're always like oh they
bought his mother a Honda court sobody
it's like dude he doesn't know what the
[__] boosters cord or whatever it is
I had one of those when I wasn't making
any money in this business Jesus [__]
Christ now now every no panties drop
over a [__] Honda ACC cord that's the
car your dad drives and drops you off at
[__] school I I I agree man you can't
blame the kid man you can't blame the
kid let's start a
petition I want to know where that
Heisman Trophy is I bet it's in some
[__] booster's goddamn living room
right
now that's Reggie bushes n it's mine
maybe you guys want some [__] no
Sneaky Pete does coke off
it all right uh no he doesn't don't you
[__] talk about my Sneaky Pete like
that Sneaky Pete is a physical specimen
the way he can still run I'll tell you
Nick Sabin can still run if you think I
was impressed Nick Sabin in the
beginning the first half and second half
the way he ran out he runs better than I
do if you think cocaine is not the
reason that 73 year old man's running up
and chewing his gum like that you got no
he can't shut it off Paul he can't shut
it off the thing about him is he looks
like that guy in The Simpsons the the
the religious guy oh mustache Flanders
Flanders he has Flanders energy
and then he [__] comes around and you
just see him dude he's chewing that gum
they they you know they do all of this
[__] for having a turkey neck when you
get over older I think Pete Carol
figured it out you just have one [__]
piece instead of chain smoking you just
keep putting that one piece of wriggle
in
there I don't know man Pete Carol's the
type of guy to be like hey you gonna
come by no we're gonna cook bring your
wife yeah bring your
wife I declin to comment on that listen
what Pete does off the [__] field is
not what I'm talking about what was her
name again Carol yeah bring her bring
her oh she seemed great no he remembers
her name he forgets you and he calls you
st it's like oh it's Paul don't make me
laugh
yeah was it Vinnie oh no no bring your
wife Carol all right we have one more
speci you wearing Cologne who wears
cologne to a
cookout couple more buttons are undone
yeah everybody's in like beach I just
came from the
gym
everybody's in pool attire he's got a
button down your wife disappears you
hear that noise what's going on in there
a just chewing some
gum all right all right Paulie Paulie
back brace
here all right all right sorry we have a
division rivalry for the special we have
the Dolphins and the bills the bills
need the win I don't care they need it I
don't care the Dolphins are going to win
this game outright oh and they're just
going to put an end to this [__]
whatever the [__] happened to bills this
year I think their biggest problem is
they're named after me a lot of people
they think it's like Buffalo Bill they
got the butt so big
misdirection um all right we'll go
Dolphins Paul I don't want to go
dolphins and listen Paul you're in the
middle of a dynasty right
now
um I love the I love the
under all right so listen man let's go
with your instincts let's go Dolphins
let's go under and let's go Tyreek Hill
for a
touchdown oh no his house just got
burned he's GNA be a little distracted
how about two with Tong of V aloa to
throw one or he could he could be
upset um I just feel like they they're
going to try to take Tyreek Hill away I
think as always they might have a little
success in the first and second quarter
and then he'll do something in the
second half but is he gonna break one
all right so how about this let's go
Dolphins under and two of a throw one I
like that all right let them Monday
night's B show Paul let's get another
one in there we only hit one this year
yeah yeah no more excuses Paul we're not
we're not we're not bringing home the
bacon for the fans here let's go out
with a
bang hey that's what she said when Pete
Carol came
over you could hear his chewing from the
ring when you have a ring at home you're
just listen you're like is that oh he's
over there no you pick up and all you
hear is the gum chewing and then he
hangs
up is an unidentified number I don't
know who that was I heard the
[Laughter]
gum H we shouldn't disparage the man
like this no it's just funny Reggie his
goddamn trophy back dude Pete Carol is
such a character that if I just walked
in and saw him and shook his hand and he
smiled I'll just burst out laughing dude
he's such a character that guy like he's
so like I don't know there's just
something about I love Carol he's a hard
guy to be in a bad mood
around you know like no and he's still
he's still wants to [__] I he he wants
to get another one Paul he's the guy's
in his seven he's he's the oldest coach
in the NFL you wouldn't know
it I'm telling
you I love Pete Carol there's just
always a pack of gum in his khakis Mak
me oh that's a
non-negotiable all right all right all
right everybody you know they went to
Seattle he loves chewing gum in the
[Laughter]
[Music]
rain oh God as the NCAA was descending
on USC he's at his hey let's get out of
here you know go Northwest it's always a
Dr out
here like a [__] chipmunk I was going
to say this is sad that his wife must
have a rule you cannot chew gum in the
[__] house no she's the game's over
spit it out oh yeah that guy's got to be
doing something at home he's on a
treadmill downstairs when they're not
that guy's active always oh he's got a
[__] TRX band he brings on the team
plane they got a little hook right in
the right in the top he's [__] doing
these laying down pulling himself up um
I was gonna say this is sad that it's
the last show but we still got the
playoffs where I [__] the bed last year
so we got uh we'll be back for oh well I
need you on one Road gig this year which
one let's do it I'm I'm playing Carolina
and then I'm playing uh Nashville
Tennessee and I'm bringing Vinnie Mark
all right now Vinnie Vinnie is he's he
he he he plays a lot of golf things were
said okay it's you and me versus him a
little Skins game here all right all
right so we got to work this guy you
know for some handicaps here because he
is you know I'm trying to protect his
image here because I know how he makes a
lot of his money he's he's a really he's
he's a decent golfer all right well
Paulie's got to get his back speaking of
handicap got get my back right but then
we're gonna do it um when is that when
is that I don't know spring I hope so I
March or what he's already hit me up
he's very excited because he feels he's
going to make more money playing golf
against us than doing two shows opening
for me and you know Paul I pay I pay my
openers
uh I want everybody to be
happy um all right everybody that's the
show um please bet responsibly and if
you want to play along with our special
and with our picks go to the BET MGM app
download it use our code uh bur B RR
it's as simple as that you put up to $10
as little as $10 into to start okay and
um if you lose your first bet you will
get
$1,500 in uh bonus bets uh after the the
initial bet gets settled okay so bet
responsibly have fun download the BET
MGM app the best app out there let's go
we got for our special the Dolphins to
win the game under 49 and a half and Tua
uh to throw a touchdown against the
bills division rival there you go this
has been week 18 we'll be back next week
for the oh my God for Wild Card Weekend
playoffs playoffs you kidding me
playoffs we'll be back uh that's the
show win a game take care